foreign
[Applause]
you're about to hear already Adams a
brilliant comedian I uh fight about like
truly nothing uh for three hours also
I'm gonna be at the Oxnard Levity Live
in Oxnard California December 8th 9th
8th 9th and 10th
um and the fact that I have to say that
is truly proof that uh you guys hate
women and that's
honestly at this point I don't know if I
blame you at all orney Adams foreign
that's your angle how'd you find that
out years of being in front of her
camera
are you self
are we rolling
yeah thank you can you cut that
um
Mark that please start over Mark that
please
what is that why do you you are very
handsome you must know that on some
level no on no level I'm fine with guys
not knowing they're hot I think we
should keep it that way but I'm just
curious
like every comedian has some kind of
dysmorphic shit you know yeah why
where'd yours come from early on I've
never I never had any confidence in my
looks I never I still don't I just yeah
why I don't know I feel like you like
I've been on a diet I said before I feel
like you know
this is not a uh you know hey I can get
more women if I act no I feel like you
do fine now I mean you're wearing a
pinky ring you must you must get women
you have the confidence or a pinky ring
but not about your hands and face yes I
I the pinky ring is to distract people
so they go whoa look at that and then
they go off the face or a guy with a
pinky ring you are a den yeah
um what what but did you in school were
you like bullied about your looks yeah I
never nobody you're the first woman to
publicly say I'm hot
you're very hot really yeah I mean my
taste is a little off but I love you in
general yeah you're hot too look at this
things are going great work that well
you just hold on will you just tell
everyone how this experience has been so
far for you coming today uh first of all
do we introduce a guest at any point or
do we just uh I'm gonna do an open when
you're gone because I don't want to deal
with your fucking shit you know let's
try it let's see how it goes okay this
comedian is one of my hold on I look
like a fucking Rat's Nest
um this comedian is one of the funniest
people I know uh he makes me laugh
kind of as much as anyone
and uh you know him from uh Teen Wolf on
him
t c
on MTV and uh he's fucking brilliant and
he has a podcast called
comedy Journal no no the top what's
wrong with buses
was Shasta but maybe this is maybe this
is why the podcast isn't doing what's
wrong with Ernie Adams yeah but maybe
it's not doing well because people they
go what's wrong with a guy sitting on a
on a shastra
maybe that's what we should rename it
what's wrong with animation today
what's wrong yeah uh with with the photo
what's wrong with just a photo of you I
didn't realize what's so I know what's
wrong with already Adams you put weird
ads for
um like Malaysian Airlines as your
podcasts are
I I guess I paid a lot of money for this
graphic and now you've made me realize
that it's ineffective you
I can you sue a graphic like can I sue
that
are we shifting cameras already no stop
being you do your job what's my job just
sit here and be sit here and look hot
honey you don't you're not let's get
back to this your brain is too small for
these big fancy machines let's get back
to this because Bobby Lee on my podcast
it declared me unfuckable
okay
and
I do have a pinky ring
don't
because I am not I imagine like here's
the thing about you I you make me laugh
kind of more than fucking anyone but I I
do think having sex with you would be
stressful
how so like I mean you have been fucking
on my fucking balls since the second you
got here this morning I show up you're
gonna you're in a uh a bathrobe from
last night yeah you're some meeting you
had until three in the morning yeah and
then
did this podcast end no and then
I just got up to check if there's food
in my teeth and then it's just
did this podcast end it's been non-stop
since I got here with you you didn't
have your coffee yet
yeah and you just said geez you know
you know horny pre-coffee this is good
this is oh this is too much
pre-coffeeorny is a lot yes uh much like
I bet pre-cum ornius a lot so so already
comes over and like I am a very
self-sufficient person but I was like I
know that when Ernie comes I'm gonna
come off like some infantilized like
fucking asshole and then of course I I
ask a rhetorical question which is would
you like some coffee and uh I no one
says yes no one's ever said yes he
always just had it already yeah we're
not even close to go time we're not she
hasn't had her coffee she's not I don't
think she's wearing that I think she's
probably gonna have to change I've got
to get a tour of the place I gotta I got
a tour of the place which was great then
I got an update on the ant situation
there's ants everywhere and you're using
you're using like flaxseed or like
Organics To Kill you're like lavender
ants don't like lavender I go this isn't
gonna work get the little traps let's
get the traps out let's do this right
then the coffee maker doesn't work
because that outlet doesn't work so
Whitney's over and over pressing the
button you know like this non-stop
trying this trying that I'm just waiting
for you to come help yeah it took me so
long well I did I I wanted you to you
know have your opportunity to figure it
out so then you can read social cues I
feel like it would be very hard to have
an orgasm and your dog is licking my
genitals as this is going on so then I
go up and I just I do this very simple I
unplug it from that outlet I put it into
this Outlet now the thing starts well I
don't know what you did to her you must
have like turned the setting for the
grind because it's grinding the beans at
exactly 50 so it's just in half so we're
gonna have the worst watery coffee ever
okay it was the grinds came out like in
like chunks of potpourri it was like
shavings that were coiled yeah it was
like it was like you ever take like a
crayon and you like it's like crayon
shaving no it's like yeah like when
people shave soap you know to like the
soothing
um uh the tank dogs I have never seen
coffee grinds look like that before ever
ever the grinds were bigger than the
beans yeah we don't know what happened
but but here's the thing you you got
this is such a fucking guy thing I think
come for me Reddit which is like why add
a step you can buy pre-ground coffee who
buys the beans and then fucking men you
guys have to turn everything into a
fucking uh like a like anything
you need something that just machines at
all times even if they're totally
unnecessary it's like the it's like do
you ride a horse to work why are we
grinding our own coffee okay I gotta you
want me to be honest yeah you're right
you're absolutely right it is everything
we need needed it's unnecessary wild
these people these coffee pundits these
people that have taken something very
simple nerds just go back to drinking
relapse have you ever what happened to
the coffee section in the supermarket is
now an entire aisle okay I have to spend
all day deciding what territory I want
my beans from what Darkness it's like
coffee's cup have a shit listen hold on
wait this is from Afghanistan I don't
know a ton about Afghani coffee didn't
know they were known for their coffee
wait do I want Afghanistan coffee for
four dollars do I want coffee from
Venice California for 62. or do I want
like fucking I mean Malaysian it's like
it's so true I'm like what country I go
what country is the poorest it probably
has the best coffee like that's what you
do you start struggling like okay these
are all third world country coffees like
that's probably better than like Sonoma
County right I I guess but here's the
thing it's too much to think about
that's why we're losing our mind right
that coffee has one purpose wake you up
get you ready for the day I argue that
not about enjoying it this is now you
gave me this I wouldn't I I wouldn't I
know I wanted that frappuccino in a
minute I'm almost done with it okay but
here's that but here's the thing is like
the coffees that I it's like makes you
fucking xenophobic and racist because
I'm like okay uh I'm gonna get this uh
Malaysian coffee great or this like you
know whatever and then you have your
this is bad fuck that place fuck those
people like it's like you're morning
coffee should not be associated with a
country that you're already not sure
about do you know what I mean like it
pushes me over the edge I I guess I
don't put that much once I get it that's
it I put it into a canister an anonymous
canister Anonymous yes and I just take
the Scoops four and a half scoops and
then always a little extra for good luck
my grandmother would always say a little
Bissell for good luck and I do that and
I think of my grandmother every day and
I have my coffee and I'm fine but here's
about five No Cry who wants to grind but
here's the thing before you've had your
coffee so the first sound you hear in
the morning is before you've had your
coffee and now your dogs think we're
under attack so they start charging they
start charging that's true and these and
you're like are you afraid of dogs your
dogs look like they can kick my ass yes
okay and I have a Rhodesian Ridgeback
who they were raised to um fight lions
you could have a wiener dog and it's
gonna it's gonna kick my ass no but you
don't dude that's what you're doing
that's what's making you not hot
I just got downgraded no you but I'm
scared of dogs just no you're not those
dogs are pretty this is what happens you
can't be scared of dogs I'm not scared
of dogs but I don't like when they jump
on you like I'll go down and be the
alpha and be like hey no okay bring the
dog in and I'll yell at the dog where's
the dog I just mean you you can't be
like oh no it isn't a puppy's gonna like
yeah but then I'm known as a guy that
goes to people's houses and yells at
their pets well don't do it like like
talk to me do it the way you talk to a
dog I don't like when I go to somebody's
house and they incorporate me into the
dog training so I walk I walk into the
house and the dog
just don't look at him just don't look
at him yeah don't look at him no they go
fight him down fight no jumping final
fight what did whatever don't make eye
contact just keep blocking me like how
what this isn't put in a fucking crate
Fido's paws are on my chest Fido is
thrusting into my genitalia you are
fuckable that's right the dogs I am and
and the Fido fight
I'm sorry he's he's being trained not to
jump well how about this until he's
fully trained let's keep him in another
room
foreign
you got to stop dating girls with studio
apartments
okay it makes me look uh more successful
and guys shave their pubes so their dick
looks bigger yes are they doing that
yeah or like you uh what's the other one
you
there's a couple like uh optical
illusion tricks I'm obsessed I remember
when I'm this is genuinely how my brain
works and I remember have you ever
pitched something to someone that you
weren't joking and they thought you were
that's how bad your idea was yeah so uh
Chuck's glar uh brilliant writer works
with Chris Rock a lot he was on uh
Everyone Hates Chris remember that show
everyone hates Chris it was about him as
a kid and the kids started growing up so
they couldn't make the show anymore
because all of a sudden the kids right
12 and he was like yeah so we can't make
the show anymore and I was like oh no no
yes you can just make a set where all
the furniture is really big
just make all the mugs really like
everything should just be bigger so they
look smaller and he started dying
laughing and I was like I guess that's
the end of my producing career because I
thought that was a great idea yeah why
not I like it I like it so um let me ask
you do I guess I just feel like to go on
a date with you I feel like would be
very stressful because you're like me
where everything that bothers no one
bothers you and everything that bothers
everyone we don't care
Give an example well I just mean I can
picture okay so if you're gonna take a
girl on a date because I'm just I'm just
thinking why don't we try the date and
let's just see I mean I don't know yeah
I don't have to fantasize about what it
would be like I'm just trying to get to
the bottom of this you saying you're
unfuckable thing I didn't say that Bobby
Lee said but you're saying it to me so
you have something because I'm just
saying it's interesting that your
opinion opinion which matters a lot more
some of these count more than mine it
doesn't I'm just saying yours counts a
lot more it should yes you men are mean
I'm now realizing because that's like in
comedy I feel like women are so mean to
women and it's hard but that you guys
are fucking here's one of my obstacles
with dating okay so I'll meet a woman
okay where uh anywhere usually it has to
be an extension of me being on stage
because on stage I'm an eight off stage
I'm a six okay so when I'm on stage
right I got it going on these women but
they all say the same thing what you
meet a lot of women it's too I'm gonna
be the one that's gonna not fall for you
right away so the perception is your
perception
you've known me how long have you known
me uh I've known of you for maybe
18 years or something when did we do
Montreal together that time the time we
first met in person I think we might
have met New York before uh so let me
just tell you the story about Ernie
Adams because I know you're gonna want
me to fucking tell it because if ever
you give a compliment to a man then you
have to every time you see him he's like
tell the story so I love that it's so
true that is true I tell the story tell
the story a lot here's the thing about
ordering when you tell the story tell
the story about Montreal is one of those
comics
most Comics I'm gonna be straight up
other Comics go I don't get it like it's
not that funny like that's how even if
we like them you know I'm not I don't do
that you said comments are saying that
about me no uh
shut your mouth
so yeah
extracting you from the store so let me
put the pinky ring over there and then
you can and so I that you do not I hope
you're not giving bitches tetanus in
their pussy from that pinky ring I hope
not so we're in Montreal this is a Gala
that's Steve Martin is hosting so at
Montreal Just for Laughs they have these
big Galas and it's a really big I mean
10 years ago I was like the biggest deal
you know it's like the Oscars of Comedy
or something it's like Montreal Comedy
Festival I I personally don't feel the
need to fly six hours to bomb for my own
agents so I don't love doing these shows
I don't know why we're all going to a
country where no one speaks English to
do comedy for that they do in Canada
they have started to incorporate more
English
into the side yeah yeah let's wait till
it's fully Incorporated part of what was
made this so exciting was Steve Martin
doesn't do live shows that's right so
we're gonna see this would be like if
Eddie Murphy was hosting a Gala like
when's the last time we saw our Eddie to
stand up so this was really kind of cool
that's a good point people have season
tickets to these Opera Houses and
theaters right and they it's half comedy
fans and half people that like will go
to whatever's there the Opera the ballet
the whatever when I tell you every
comedian bombed in a way that was like
confusing even like no joke really is
this is the is the mic work just Cur
like we literally we're saying is this
thing on bombing our dicks off orney is
last okay and I come off someone else
goes on bombs and then you're about to
go on and we're like good luck buddy
like you know Ernie is already kind of
on the edge this is getting my push-up
over the edge you know owning us on
stage immediately
starts killing in a way that is so is
wild like it actually changed my life
because I was like oh it's never the
audience's fault it's never the
audience's fault and um because you just
went up it was like that we were we were
all gathering around to watch you bomb
and like and like flip out on the
audience you're like dude Ernie is not
gonna handle this well like yeah because
I would flip out yeah I would I would
break that wall I'd leave the stage I'd
point at people I'd yell at them we're
about to watch already Adams have like
an epic meltdown that'd be cool I was
like this is gonna be so fun so we're
all like watching and we're like we
can't wait to see order bombed so we
feel good about our bombs like this
would be so fun to watch and you just
started killing we were doing the bit
about um the customer service in India
me calling third us calling third world
countries yes with our problems like
it's so obnoxious right I mean it's
horrible okay it's great it's great you
can still do it
like we're calling India to be like yeah
my five computers of the Wi-Fi is not
connecting yeah yes it's so insensitive
it was just like it's taking me 30
seconds to load a video like can you
guys can you get out of the river that
you're washing yourself in and and then
drinking the water from later do you
think you could I think uh I think my
fridge is uh it's it's not working
what's the uh the warrant you know it
was like that all the food in my fridge
is going back can you help me yeah isn't
it wild when you can't even remember
what used to be like your one of your
favorite bits it's weird yeah it's
really weird it here's the thing that I
remember and Dane Cook was on that show
too and here's the thing that I remember
oh well I remember this don't don't
address Steve don't go hey thank you
Steve yeah don't look at Steve not that
he said that but like because they may
take the set and isolate it and then uh
put it like on another Gala like the
so-and-so get whoever I mean they could
also just cut out you saying
Thanksgiving sorry that's what I said so
I go this is once in a lifetime and I
felt like I had a good set I really did
and I said uh before I left I said can I
shake your hand and he walked across the
stage and he started bowing to me oh
Steve Martin and I have this on on tape
he was following but whatever yeah he
then and then I bowed to him literally
like
you are I mean there's only a couple
comedians that when other comedians talk
about you when you're not around
everyone's like he's fucking funny as
shit oh like no one says you're not like
no one no not one
don't fight with me about this why not
try it I'm sure okay I love it I think
that's that's great because I don't I I
have deep insecurities about how the
comedy community feels about me yeah I
don't I'm universally beloved
well I I listen I I love you I think
you're great and I love I love our
friendship and I love and that how it's
evolved yeah and how it went from you
not returning my text message are we
friends yes we're friends for sure for
sure okay any woman that says come on in
in a robe brings me right up to her
bedroom and says this is the best view I
go that's all right I am and what did I
say I am a sexual predator but okay in
10 years we would have been like it was
like Harvey Weinstein it was like right
Open Secret when he was just in robes
bringing men to her home and being like
you need to be able to fuck me you're
fuckable let's go I think I'm being
taken advantage of by somebody more
powerful in Show Business and it's not
that bad it's not that bad
so not to demand what has happened to
other people disclaimer
I understand some people did get hugged
too long and I won't stand for it let's
get back to Montreal for a second
because I think it's fascinating do you
still believe there's no such thing as a
bad audience
I think it is a comedian's job
there's no audience you cannot crack and
when you go like you didn't love my
first joke and now that's you did that I
was at this it's your job to get it's
your job yeah to figure out what will
make them laugh it is if you turn on
them they're like ducky then fuck them
like they came they no one comes to a
comedy show to not laugh they're on your
side all right I'm gonna tell you
something if you're if you're a young
comic and you're watching or you're just
a comedian in general what you just said
is absolutely true and that's the
greatest advice that you can give
somebody you have to crack it every
artist accountability yes so Saturday
night I was at the Improv comic after
comic went on and just did not do well
to the point where like Comics that
usually like kill were coming off stage
deflated and I went up there and I just
said listen
um every comic thinks you suck yeah yeah
they think you suck okay and you don't
you guys are great the last guy he's
retired he's out of the business that's
what you did to him the guy before him
there's a guy who's talking about a
terrible disease I don't want to say
which one I said he walked off stage and
he said that is now not the lowest point
of my life performing in front of that
audience is and I just kept going and
then they they love and they started
applauding and applauding and it was
like and even you and I like that night
that we went up on stage together we
created a moment we created something
that gives them something to talk about
because they can see Whitney Cummings
any night or you know many nights doing
comedy and me doing comedy but to see us
together and the other thing is when you
watch it on on YouTube if you saw these
clips of us you would think oh this is a
put on this and they'll come out soon
it's basically I came off stage I left
my phone on stage because I'm uh
physically incapable of walking out of a
space without leaving half of the things
I came in with and then I was like or
when he was on stage I was like oh my
god my phone's up there with him I'm
about to get fucking destroyed when I go
up on stage and there's like somebody's
old take your drink clear your table
like you know like there's stuff on the
stage I want a Zen peaceful stage when I
think Courtney Adams I think Zen
peaceful what it really turned into
which is really interesting and cool was
unbeknownst to you or perhaps to you
there was underlying tension in our
newfound friendship because we had
exchanged numbers and I said hey you
know I'd love to you know have you on my
podcast or have you jump up and do yours
you were serving me uh jury duty summons
basically yeah I get you know I was like
you know what Whitney Cummings needs
another to do
she needs another today I know people
are like I know you're busy I know you
have a lot going on but like can you
drive to Thousand Oaks for six and a
half hours for free I'm like are you are
you that busy because people think I'm
really that busy and I'm not they think
you are yeah they go oh how do you have
time I'm like yeah you know I'm sitting
around watching 90 Day Fiance everyone
is so so stressed out and overwhelmed
because they only have two hours of
clarity a day I'm like just just don't
do Edibles during the week see how much
you get done it comes back to what we
were talking about before too many
choices like with the coffee coffee is
one purpose you want caffeine you want
to get the buzz you got to start the day
you gotta confront this crappy World
okay like you ever see the old movies
the old movies are like you walk into
the office and go hey can I get you a
drink and there's a one decanter and
they pour the drink and the person
drinks it because the objective is to
get the buzz yeah to relax nowadays
we're like oh what is that it's bourbon
what kind of bourbon what year is it
what shape is your ice I've had women
comment on the shape of my ice cubes in
my house okay that's where we're it's
like shut up take a drink and drink
we're not and you shut up and face your
camera you don't have to enjoy you don't
have to enjoy every every sip of every
beverage the objective of the drink is
get a buzz and then we open up and we
have a good night together but I knew
where I need a jalapeno and a daffodil
they need Industrials they need the
lavender the lavender Bush coming out of
it they need like it's it's you just go
I I want to get drunk but I also want to
feel like I just uh gagged on a farmer's
market
sorry this isn't a uh this isn't a craft
cocktails bar but I have round ice cubes
you're like
a shot of vodka with a roofie in it just
fucking drink it yeah just we're here to
get drunk so okay but in the movies
that's it yeah I want that so you're
um so the last person what's the longest
relationship you were in years I like
I'm a commitment guy so I cannot picture
it
that someone would put up with me no
that that someone would not take it
personally why like that someone's not
you can't you and I both can't be with
people that are sensitive
no because I say things that are wrong
all the time unbeknownst like I'm not
I'm not being malicious but I'm just you
know like I have a hot take
is this a segment you do hot take
there's a graphic on the screen right
now that says hot takes
so I I will say something and then
decide if I believe it like that like
I'm going to I'm just going to get
granular about like so what is the point
of being alive if everyone agrees on
everything all the time it doesn't say
anything wrong otherwise we're just in a
huddle right otherwise we're just like
yeah you like that movie love that movie
great then what we're the appetizer
hasn't even come like we have taken away
the well maybe it could be this oh
that's interesting and then I'm gonna
agree with you in like three minutes
sometimes you're on the fence so you say
it and you want to hear the other person
convince you out of it because I'm
malleable I'll I'll change you can
change my opinions or it might be 80
right like I want to know you know so I
think that this to this but that oh
great that's a good point okay now I oh
how am I supposed to know anything if I
don't say the wrong thing like I don't
Bel I say something and then I'll decide
if it's true or not well this is this is
two I have two thoughts and we'll start
with the first thought that I have it's
very important what you're talking about
discourse because nowadays there's no
discourse it's straight to cancel and
it's okay can I say something it's okay
it's okay to be wrong and it's okay to
be convinced that you're wrong and say
you know what now that I've talked to a
few people be wrong then pretend I'm
right and I'd rather be interesting and
that's the most important that's our job
as comedians our job is not to be right
is not to be loved it is to like you
know we're the core jesters and you know
uh someone's talking about this the
other day that the role of the Court
Jester the role of that in uh you know
16 17 1800s with royalty it was to make
sure that the royalty still had a sense
of humor about themselves because if
you're if you don't laugh something's up
with you right it was literally to make
sure it was to make sure that the
leaders were like still sane and weren't
ego maniacal like do you ever do those
corporate gigs yeah a lot I do those
corporate gigs and you roast the CEO yes
and the CEO knows like it they'll tell
you what to make fun if they love it
because the peasants don't look at the
past give the crumbs to The Peasants let
them laugh you know they all joke that
Bob's on the boat every weekend I can't
believe Bob's here for the event and
he's not out on the boat I did this
corporate event um for this company
called lion tree it's amazing uh and uh
I'd like to do it next year it was a lot
of it was a like every one it was like
every head of every TV network had a
discovery plus had a like the founder
Discovery plus was there uh
I gotta do this really it was like
everything was the luggage channel that
was like the most powerful people in the
world are right there and I was uh in a
lot of sweet TV there was wheat Whitney
this is a huge gig for me what what else
was what there's only fans TV there were
these to be too much that of Roku the
head of quibby was there Jeffrey what's
there exactly TV and Mike was Myspace TV
there
oh my Alta Vista video was that there
was AOL
with the streaming service oh my God
realistic Global was there uh Pinterest
all of them oh my God I gotta get this
is a huge this would be such a big
opportunity if I could be in front of
all these these these Mogul this would
be amazing
it would change my career who else was
there here's the thing
who kills me is that what year because
you're like I think you're gonna be like
you're like the Rodney are Rodney
Dangerfield like in terms of you're
gonna get so famous and so successful
and you're gonna fucking blow your
brains out because it's like you love
shitting on your own career which is
like the funniest thing ever but you're
gonna get really successful and then
you're gonna seem like a bully I would
yeah you're in the sweet spot right now
where you can do that and you're not an
asshole I wouldn't know what to if
everybody liked me or like I had Mass I
wouldn't know what to do I wouldn't I'm
worried for you yeah I would not know
what because I've been the underdog my
whole life yeah high school you know
like I was like tangentially in the cool
group but I wasn't sure you know Frank
Frank tutori had a party Frank tutori I
love high school names man they're
always wild I have been trying to figure
out where this guy is because this guy
had he lived his house backed into my
house and he had a party where'd you go
uh Lexington Massachusetts he had at a
party and the guest list was limited to
because she couldn't have everybody
right it was limited this is high school
like junior year listen first of all
Frank tutori this guy came out of
nowhere he was from Guam okay all of a
sudden he's the cool kid I put in I put
in like 10 solid years with this group
of people to be the cool kid Frank comes
out of nowhere swoops and all of a
sudden people like Frank's cool he's
exotic he's from Guam this is before
Google nobody even knew what Guam was
okay turns out Guam's not that sexy but
Frank was cool Frank decides to have a
party okay the guest list which is
limited he told me apparently included
everybody in the school except me okay
so it was the entire school and probably
people from the schools and you know
Jason towns minus me and my house was
right there and this is how pathetic I I
was I said Frank if somebody doesn't
show up can I
stop it gets worse it gets now the
producer's Laughing it gets worse
I said Frank because he lived in an area
this is before MapQuest and by the way
MapQuest TV was at that convention too
this is before this is before MapQuest
or Siri or whatever Apple Maps he had it
was a weird turn into his street and I
lived on the Main Street so I said Frank
what if I directed traffic right and
then I came into the park this is
this is this is how pathetic I was okay
and you wonder why I'm curious if people
like me now Frank has disappeared he's
like a ghost I can't find him anywhere
but I never I never went you did I never
went to oh oh
first I'd show him my set and just
relaxed Montreal with Steve Martin
that's what I'd show him it is wild how
much of a grip like one high school
trauma can do to your the rest of your
life there was one girl but you know it
started way before that good news and
bad news yeah there was one girl and I
don't want to say her name but I
remember where we were because it was
the exact same classroom it's like
eighth grade I love high school names
this is how you find the people you're
looking for you're talking about a lot
of podcast and they'll reach out to you
but her name was like it was like Genie
listen what happened it was just say her
name what's her name I don't know it was
tragic she was sitting mid row okay I
was behind her yeah I love your accent
yeah uh and the way I say pillow you
ever see when I'm on stage I go pillow
and people correct me like I didn't know
what correcting people we're pillow
shaming the way people say fellow anyway
this this is this is tragic okay she was
already too tall for her age
it sort of picked on and um and I felt
bad for her but one day in uh social
studies class she sneezed mid classroom
so she's sitting a few chairs back I'm
behind her because I was cool enough to
be behind some people in the classroom
oh listen back row cool anyway she
sneezed that I literally have never
thought about that she sneezed where are
you what role you sit in is based
basically how cool you are well I mean
the dorks are up front I've never
thought the legit nerds and by the way I
grew up when they were real nerds real
nerds like they didn't want to be nerds
like but they couldn't like headgear
motherfucker that's weird and like
pocket protector type people real nerd
nice is like fucking train tracks not
just fake Silver Lake put on okay that
was like bleeding just like incredible
losers
and they
by the way style now so they're winning
and they they started mine yeah
they were they they started Facebook and
they started running Hollywood yeah you
know how they got back on us algorithms
they started algorithms they're screw
with people like me so anyway she
sneezed Christina she sneezed I don't
want to say your name Christine she
sneezed you don't know it and oh admit
you don't know loogie came out of her
mouth and it was it was going like this
and the whole class was like slow-motion
and it hit the board the teacher is to
the left writing
loogie on the board and no way teacher
pretends that that doesn't see did you
go to call a school in a tiny wooden
school house no this was yeah Louisa May
Alcott I went to school with her school
The Crucible yeah yeah it was The
crucial it was The Crucible Church yeah
I went to a I was uh part of the the
what do they call the people that make
the silverware those people no not the
Amish I don't like silverware they make
um dressers and stuff like that makes
the silverware the uh ownids or
something Onida I don't know Oneida
Oneida but who's the group shakers how
does Pat knows everything Quakers and
shakes first of all Pat doesn't know
everything Pat's for nothing for an hour
we've been thinking non-stop if I was
doing nothing like Pat's over there you
know on his dating app or something
is Ashley Madison still around oh
remember it was a dating site for
married people Ashley Madison TV I have
a deal coming up with them that I got I
was at that convention that uh that you
were performing at so I didn't even get
to say my rose joke
we're gonna get to that she the loogie
she never lived that down to this day
you don't that's her life's over she
should have just done that Junior High
so she's still yeah yeah so I remember I
remember the night of Frank tutorials
party we will need to check on her we
were spooning together we're the only
two that weren't invited are you in the
loogie yeah you and Louie Christina oh
yeah I don't know uh you're like can you
do that Louie on my dick bitch whoa wow
we didn't speak like that when I was
coming up first of all we were not so
enlightened as these young people with
sex we didn't have online resources we
sort of had to figure it out ourselves I
love you
love yours like I remember when it came
time for me to um you know get it on for
the first time yeah I didn't know you
had to take your hand and guide it in
okay
and that was with a uh a younger
erection
[Music]
what did you fucker in the asshole by
accident no it happened I hit the thigh
and I was done have you ever
eggs happen fast in those days
oh no the sets
for this My Girl Scout cookie that I
want to eat wait really quick have you
ever had a boba tea am I sweating is it
getting hot in here have you ever yes
yeah with those things yeah yeah I had
my first boba tea the other day with
Howie Mandel right no because that's who
I had my first one with really like
three weeks ago oh that's so weird yeah
no this was here I was like really sick
and I was trying to figure out something
that I could actually eat and not puke
up and uh I had my first boba tea and it
literally felt like
when a guy is fucking you and then like
just tries to put in your butt real
quick you're like oh whoa like it you
never or like when you're sucking a
guy's dick and he put his hand on the
back of your head and just like without
telling you you know okay so let me let
me get this boba tea feels like to me
okay so let me get this straight you're
just like this is going great and
they're like oh like it's too much okay
so the lesson what's up boba tea the
lesson I was raped by a boba ball
wow I was gonna say so the lesson is
that you love bubble tea
now that it is
give me a heads up first well I'll be
honest with you my experience was a lot
different with the bubble tea yeah I
didn't feel assaulted at all I'd rather
enjoyed it I loved it so why okay so is
this a Massachusetts like a guy thing or
a guy in his 40s thing that you change
the name of things for no reason I don't
know what the Bobo is it's Boba okay but
but it's not a body part the bowl but
the vulva the bowl I was on the phone
with the other day he's like I'm in
Nordstrom it's Nordstrom no why do men
pluralize department stores okay first
of all Whitney who was clearly in
control of the communication levels of
this friendship okay it starts with me
texting her twice she not returning my
text which leads us to stage on stage at
The Improv and me attacking her for her
for this okay which led to a really
funny moment we're gonna release the
clips now Whitney jumps to the FaceTime
I would never be that bold you picked up
I picked up and what was I wearing
nothing that's right I thought
I was in physical therapy my shirt was
off and I thought well you know we need
to get you into mental therapy physical
therapy that's not very nice and I
disagree it's just the order of
priorities here priority is my body well
let's get into that in a minute so now I
I'm gonna write things down I downgrade
to
phone call because I'm not gonna like
you I figure you're you're busy so I'm
not gonna FaceTime you back or maybe I
so I phone call you don't pick up again
you're controlling the tempo of the
communication I was in in a meeting or
something okay now I don't pick up when
I'm in something well I was excited you
were calling I'm like this is a big deal
this is this is like you know what I
mean it was a pocket dial okay now I
said it yeah so anyway then you call
back a few minutes later I'm in
Nordstrom
but thank you say
you said where are you
it's coming in a little intense here are
you I'm at Dominic Nordstrom's buying
shoes now I'm thinking this is going to
impress I just ran off the road
first of all she's gonna think finally a
guy who cares about his shoes he's got
the money the shop in Nordstrom this
isn't like the last guy who's trying to
impress you with whole whole grain
coffee beans or whole coffee beans this
is a real I'm in Nordstrom not only that
I got like two or three people around me
boxes boxes this is like Pretty Woman
okay they're excited they're seeing
dollar signs big mistake huge yeah so I
say I made I'm at Nordstrom's buying
shoes and you go why do men do that oh
my God I'm upset Whitney what what did I
do am I I'm not supposed to be in
Nordstrom's is this is this 10 years ago
where I should have been buying is there
a new place and she was why do men
pluralize everything like what do you
mean Nordstrom's I'm like Oh my she's so
upset well maybe I was in two Nordstroms
at the same time this is how you come
off too right yeah probably
I program my name and his phone is WC
and he like had a conniption about it
because I couldn't find you and I had to
call people I just go I I have Whitney's
number but you put it in the phone as WC
which is water closet that's my plumber
is under WC okay and so I couldn't find
you so somebody had to give me your
number then I put it in and wc comes up
you couldn't just put Whitney Cummings I
mean it's like it's a little it feels
like it's a little this feels like um
there's this is something that should be
uh like slightly frustrating and it to
you is like a nervating yes uh yeah
irate yeah I mean you could have a w
coming it's like I'm doing Whitney I'm
doing come I'm spelling it different
ways W maybe there's maybe it's h maybe
it's hit me Cummings maybe it's you know
Cummings with a k i you know I'm trying
like everything and uh and then it
didn't matter because I text you and you
don't return the text
so I changed it now so if anybody wants
to hack my phone you can get Whitney's
number I'll change it to with me
and leave my numbers on Reddit who cares
yeah why didn't you just go on Reddit my
number I get doxed all the time everyone
is my number but you yeah do you return
the Reddit people's tax I'm sure you do
sometimes yeah I'm just like fuck it
yeah um okay so the uh uh one of the
Rose jokes I did at like just to the
point of people love being roasted if
you do it right uh and people that sign
up for it enjoy it like we're what we're
doing now is we're giving com we're
pushing comedy on people for free by the
way uh on Twitter and during the day
when no one wants comedy you talk about
us yes yeah we're doing this yeah I'm
actually uh uh Like Comics need to stop
but like here's the thing no no here's
the problem hold on
take hot take everybody is it hot in
here is it hot in here I think what
you're trying to say yes
yeah I'm gonna say it just let me I'm
not trying to say it I'm saying okay not
as quickly as you want me to because
you're making me fucking fluster comedy
is meant to be delivered in the dark at
night when you have a drink and no one
can see and you're not necessarily okay
well you do festivals cool during the
day you do comedy at 2 p.m
congratulations but hold on let me
finish which is and we don't know
uh what we're going in between so we go
I'm gonna do this abortion joke or Roe v
Wade overturning joke and then I send it
out there and I assume everyone follows
who I follow I assume everyone's
following comedians yeah not true unless
you know so you can't control what tweet
your your below and above so that great
abortion joke could have gone below a 10
toddlers just got shot in the face at an
elementary school and Trump's running
again and then you've got your Roe v
Wade thinking people like fuck this and
it's two o'clock and they're at work
right so I think that this whole thing
of like we're getting canceled so we'll
stop doing comedy for people that aren't
comedy fans I would be really fucking
annoyed at football if I was like doing
what I do and someone's like football
you need to learn about fun look at this
football play and I'm like I'll watch
football when I turn it on I'll watch
football when I go to a football game
don't push it on me when I don't want it
right we're doing that and then we're
mad people aren't like uh we're jamming
free comedy down their throats and we're
mad when they're like I'm at work can
you not right I I think I think you're
correct that comedy written doesn't work
as well as comedy we tweet a thing and
then we're wondering why people are
offended because they delivered it the
way the they're not Comics even Steve
Martin who has such a defined voice
had trouble on Twitter with the arrow it
was misunderstood no you didn't you know
he just they people don't get it so yeah
I tweet a lot less that's not where
comedy should be where should it be Tick
Tock in Tick Tock Instagram Stories
Comedy is such a recent invention you
know it is stand up yeah I mean it's not
that recent it's been going off 100
years 80 years they've been there
stand-up comedy yeah they used the
philosophers used to like do sort of you
know this type of thing yeah which ones
I don't know I might have made that
album yeah yeah
feel like you don't have Socrates first
first album I mean is it Descartes
killed Descartes had the best closure of
all the philosophers such fucking hacks
hey y'all me again here to talk about
your body there's nothing comedians like
talking about more than other people's
bodies and all their crevices all their
curves and all their edges and all their
Perfect Imperfections
such a great service that uh
you know I understand that the people
working there are having to like come up
with ways to sell it yeah I don't think
you need to it's the best thing in the
world because one day your boss is gonna
look at you and go
find a doctor who will fix my
costochondritis and first you have to
figure out how to spell that but do you
really want to throw stones no in
pronounceable conditions correct but I
really want to throw kidney stones but
I'm just saying you could just go on
ZocDoc you can type that baby right in
and it'll say here are seven doctors or
however many doctors in your area who
will fix that problem for your boss and
if you don't even have to call them
ZocDoc is genius you it's like uber for
Doctor that's exactly am I allowed to
say that yeah I don't know or like
grinder for doctors it is that's what it
it's Tinder for doctors it's like you're
able to find a doctor in your area that
actually takes your insurance they can
see a picture of them so you know if
they're creepy also not like like a
that's a factor but also real doctors
right not like gurus they're not like
like magicians
chiropracticial degrees medical degrees
people that went to uh college with
tools and little mini hammers that hit
your knee like real they have tongue
depressors say uh ZocDoc is a free app
that shows you doctors who are patient
reviewed take your insurance very
important and are available when you
need them go to zocdoc.com Whitney and
download the ZocDoc app for free why not
do it then start your search for a
top-rated doctor today many are
available within 24 hours Game Changer
that
zocdoc.com Whitney zocdoc.com
Whitney uh okay let's talk about blizzy
blissy Blissey is a silk pillowcase
company I have been talking about silk
pillowcases since I had a Blog 20 years
ago called
princesscomplex.com it was a Tumblr uh
fucking
do your own research on that you tin
foil hat door okay so people ask me why
do I have such good skin no like it's uh
you know not because I eat babies you
can't do that anymore what I do is I've
always been sleeping on silk pillowcases
because what happens is you put the
product on your face before you go to
bed all these incredible night creams
and serums and all the stuff that you're
spending all your money on and then you
put your face on the still on the
regular pillowcase and the cotton
absorbs everything it also gets all the
moisture out of your hair which is why
your hair breaks and it's dry and why
you look like Phil Spector exactly yeah
so so pillowcases also when you sleep at
night
um uh it makes it so that your skin
isn't just being like dragging on itself
yeah exactly so you're not gonna wake up
you know and look like um
people on Reddit say I look exactly
Grace take it away
um Blissey is the perfect thing to get
somebody for the holidays the holidays
are right around the corner why not give
them the gift of better sleep and it
comes in like a gorgeous little box
tissue paper it comes like it's a
perfect the bar is low for Grace you
guys I you could give me if you think
the box is awesome wait till you see
what's inside like a child of the
depression I'm like yeah box is enough
so Grace's favorite part of the product
is this that's beautiful paper
okay but it's but you get a little you
get a little mask okay you get a little
night mask I sleep with one of these
every night yeah
um from Blissey and it's truly changed
my life they're so comfortable they're
so soft it comes in like a beautiful
little drawstring bag you pull that out
on a plane people are like upgrade her
she should be in first class why is she
back here in the middle seat in economy
try it now risk free for 60 nights and
get an additional 30 off that's
b-l-i-s-sy dot com slash Whitney and use
our code to get an additional 30 off
your skin and hair will thank you
b-l-i-s-s-y it's a pillow company not
Hooked on Phonics I think that comedians
are things like first amendment I can
say whatever I want and someone's like I
don't think that's funny we're like no
First Amendment for you like that's
bratty it's fucking bullshit comedians
like this has always happened we're not
supposed to hear the feedback we're not
supposed to it's like you know when you
I agree you know when you leave a venue
and there's crowds of people talking
about the show I will just turn around
because someone's going I love this but
like this I don't I'm so afraid they all
have the right to have all the opinions
I think if you're coming to my show
you're pretty happy whatever but like
we're not supposed to hear people's
feedback you're supposed to make a movie
and put it out you get the box office
and then you assume anyone that didn't
come wasn't interested right like we
we've always the numbers speak the
numbers used to change right so it used
to be like oh your movie made three
million dollars it was a bomb and you're
like yeah these all these people said no
thank you right they didn't even go in
to then say I hate this but like that
was we didn't focus on that because it
was like we're not supposed to hear the
water cooler conversation people have to
talk about entertainment a movie comes
out I hated it I loved it what we just
talked about before whether they believe
it or not it doesn't matter you have to
have an opinion and we're just hearing
their opinions and I believe that you
know people that hate Comics people that
are trashing us they're our best
publicists they're they're helping us I
hate it I know but then don't read it
but I I try not to but what bothers me
is when they're so wrong on the facts
when it's not even close this is what
happened to me this is what happened to
me so but you have to accept that
comedians we are obsessed with truth
we're obsessed with Justice a lot of
people do not have time to do they say
sloppy shit that's trash I hated that
like but they need to do that it's fine
female comedians the most hated species
of people on the planet don't you think
um
I don't know if most hated species see
this is why no you can't date anyone
you're so you know what I'm saying and
you're intentionally taking it literally
for no reason I'm sorry but can't we
have discourse can we discuss discourse
earlier this is why you can't date
anybody because if if you say anything
wrong you just snap yeah that's who you
and you are like to get a mirror because
because Whitney Cummings I don't want
you to feel that I don't want you to
have that complex I I think female
comedians are having their time I think
that there's there's now yeah I never
talk I know I am the person that is like
we forgive others not because they
deserve it so we can deserve peace I
didn't sign it I didn't say I I said I
want to be able to make a living doing
comedy I never sat on my vision board
every single person has to love me if if
they do you're probably not a very good
comedian right you know what I'm saying
like I don't want you can't be loved by
everything if you are loved by everyone
I would I wouldn't be I'm boring
something's wrong yeah something's wrong
you're not taking risks like you're not
you know and so but I do agree there is
a prejudice against female communities
I'm trying to be nice to the host and
then I was going to tell Alex or Mike
whatever his name is we edit that out
like Pat edit that up Mark it edit it
out there is no Prejudice female
comedians are all doing better than me
as far as I can tell
okay I'm doing my podcast I had a a
Shasta which Whitney could even get the
graphic right what's wrong with it with
a truck she called it a truck
I don't know what the fuck that is dude
there's a thing for kerosene oil there's
a microphone this is all hand drawn I
give up I retire today the image I just
don't think it should be your podcast
image okay well get me a new one like
you how do you pick art that makes you
less famous
what are you doing I don't know I've
done everything wrong I really I gotta
get out I think it's time for me to
retire I think it's time no this is that
this is this is like this is the time
for you like it's gonna it's about to be
your time I don't know what are you
basing that on because it's because
convenience it's like the best is always
Yet to Come As long as you don't lose
your mind or kill yourself or get sick
like I think comedians are at their best
oh so you don't see anything particular
in my you're the best you've ever been
and you're only to get better and now
people are really talking about you you
know you have like a really big setback
you know I don't even think we need to
talk about it like if just like you were
introduced to the world in a way that
was just like not fair you know and uh
people now are like that that's fucking
you know the one thing I will say is
that
um if that didn't happen and you had
become like a sensation when you were
like whatever 25 30 and been the most
maybe the universe maybe that wouldn't
have right like served me well for me I
don't I personally don't really want to
get any more famous like I I it's like I
know it doesn't end well for anyone
makes you a Target life gets way less
fun you know it's really hard to make to
know why people want to be friends with
you it's really stressful it's really
like you know I'm not complaining I like
no it all makes sense I know
psychologically when I look back and I'm
like I didn't get this and I didn't get
this I'm like had I gotten it I probably
would have
I think you got it I think you've done
very well thank you but I look at things
I've mostly failed no I I admire and
respect you so much for what you've
accomplished in your work I really do
and and on that note
give me give me career advice I'd be
curious okay we'll get to in a sec we'll
get time because I really and I saw you
sort I saw I should I shouldn't have
interrupted myself because I saw a
visceral looking your eye that me saying
that you know made me physically ill no
I think it uh this is why you're single
I think it touched you I think I think
it's good for you to hear that like
you did it you did what nobody else has
done I mean I wish I could have created
my own sitcom I would and I would have
called it Whitney I wish I wish
Christine girl yeah I wish I bet I'm the
same height as her now I wish
I wish I could have created another show
called Two Broke Girls and just bought
properties all over Southern California
by the way this is my favorite this is
why I mean no one makes me fucking level
you so uh which is tricky because I go
like the funniest people a lot of times
are the most discontent people and can't
enjoy and just we see the world in a way
that no one else sees it and I think the
things that most people enjoy we don't
get it and that you know so I do in my
backyard I have like a mountain like a
beautiful view and uh during the
pandemic a lot of my friends had movies
coming out in specials and they couldn't
do premieres they said a good story so I
was doing these outdoor screenings for
my friends and we'd have like
influencers over people when we post it
and then so I I spent all this like I'm
like I should do an outdoor screening
room because it seems like this whole
pandemic thing might not go away and
Schultz his he came over like we put a
special up like I'm having like let's
have premieres here that no one is where
we're going so I have these like swings
it's really a wonderful mall I I don't
enjoy it I'm with you I'd never go over
there except when someone comes over to
show them yeah and uh and so I put the
screen down I'm like trying didn't like
go like already look at this yeah yeah I
could try to press you part of the tour
I put the screen down
outdoor screening room it's like it's
pretty fucking amazing we did I did MTV
Cribs recently and it's like you know
it's like the cool moment and he was
like well this blocks The View yeah she
just walk The View
made no sense to me well it's a
beautiful view screen comes down now my
viewers Andrew Schultz
that's not what I paid all this money
for for this property well I could do
that at my house
I couldn't believe it
and then then the screen starts going up
and I'm like is this part of the tour
over like I thought we were gonna
project something on the screen I
thought you're going to show me like how
many like you know how great and clear
the image is Scream beautiful view
mountains there's deer there's mountain
lions there's there's foliage there's no
foliage anyway it's fall in California
there's no fall in California except
outside of Whitney's house this street
now I'm staring at a blank screen which
is how I would Define my career and
Whitney goes uh I go what's that I just
lost the view she goes but isn't this
great
the view just I was enjoying the view
and then the screen goes up Whitney
walks away and I now this is how the
entire tour of the property goes we had
to get started and I had to get dressed
I have to go Whitney am I supposed to
fall
how do you not know like oh yeah I'll
just follow her
by the way he sat in a chair that is
like the only chair I have that's not
dangerous yeah I almost fell out in my
house he sat in it like it was a rocking
chair you just said you have to tell me
you have to go to the tour continues now
it's two inches this chair is literally
two inches off the ground there's no way
to injure he's just sat in it okay
imagine if I sat next to you on the
swing how creepy that would have been
flip you with the screen hey come on
come over and view this do the screen
why is sitting on a swing with a man so
sexual like why can't two grown adults
sit on a swing and it not be a date
because Whitney there were about eight
other seating options around it so if
I'm sitting on the swing stuff's
happening stuff is going down okay and
I'm not talking about the screen
let me ask you a question and then the
tour continues and this is like I go
what's happening oh now we're over here
then we go sit in another section okay
so he goes why do you live out here and
I'm like let me show you and he's like
why are you showing me yeah well even
just first of all getting off the
highway and the from the highway to the
house I'm not I'm not doing that there's
already two we we're doing it you sound
you sound just like Bobby Lee on my
pocket I'm not doing this
by the way we don't have headsets and
this still works why do podcasts have
headsets it is it's you know what I
think it is I think it's a prop yeah
that uh not for not for Rogan Rogan it's
the the headset is a really big part of
it well just kind of like it's um I
don't know for some reason on Rogan
there's something psychological about
about just uh
I think being in it it's like a
pavlovian thing I don't know why I mean
his voice is so hypnotic
I love it because I you know I have like
tourettese OCD where I like interrupt
people when I get excited and I I can't
control it all the time I'm on uh Prozac
now and it's helpful I'm glad you're
aware of this
I want to bring it up I have it on my my
notes on my phone to bring it up but
after the podcast I didn't want to talk
about on the podcast we talk about
everything on the bike okay okay when
you after after you there will never
make eye contact again unless it's on
the bike see that's my thing is like I I
don't know when comedians are around
each other off camera we're kind of just
like like I don't know I for some reason
on podcast I feel like we're bringing
out our best I'm new to this I knew I've
been closed and not open I'm not I'm not
a good question I'm joking horrible but
why don't I you're an amazing ass I I
you're killing me my My Philosophy from
the beginning of my career starting in
Boston then New York was to go in do my
work do the best work I can and then
just go home and go home and write and
take notes after shows and say this one
right this went wrong and and and really
Master the craft yeah you really are I
love writing I love coming here I like
the car a cobbler I I am a cobbler I am
I'm the guy you go to and you say my my
joke is broken and I love that about you
but yeah I love that about you because I
think a lot of people now are just like
I write on stage and I'm like what I am
such a fucking dork about comedy because
I care so much about the audience and I
care so much about like entertaining
them and this whole thing of like having
a notebook just be like what else is
happening yeah anyway what are you it's
just like I saw one time at the Pasadena
ice house it changed me forever and I'm
curious about moments in your life that
like you know I think sometimes it takes
a long time to change something about
yourself but then something happens and
it's like boom done I did that would
have taken me 10 years had I not seen
this thing or experience this moment
which I was at the passing ice house and
I always watch I like to watch I love
comedy like I love comedian I I watch
people's sets yeah I also want to know
what people are doing so I want to make
sure I'm never doing anything close and
so I'm at the Pasadena ice house I'm on
next and someone's on
uh whatever comic it was was like uh Hey
so where are you from and then the
person was like a Mississippi or
whatever it was and then he's like okay
what about you where are you and a man
stood up in the third row and went he's
from Florida he's from Pasadena he's
from Texas can you please just tell some
fucking jokes wow
and it changed my brain forever in what
way well because I was just like I am
never going to uh well coming up as a
comic seeing so many uh successful
comedians waste stage Time by being like
anyway what else is going on or doing
stuff that they've already done in
specials or just being self-indulgent I
was like I will never do that because
I'm sitting here ready to fucking
entertain these people and you're kind
of just like it is a privilege to be on
stage I I take it really really
seriously I'd love to hear that and you
have all day to prepare
what's your job yeah it's like when
Comics come up and like anyway what else
is happening it's like you had to work
15 minutes today like just cancel
something there's 19. I'll tell you I'll
tell you a secret I have and I'll go on
stage tonight and I have an objective
every time I have notes and I hit this
hit this sometimes it's one line and
this is why you're not Union bomb like
the other ones because a lot of people
go on and they just go like oh well I've
been funny before so I'm gonna Coast
half the people there don't know you and
they're like I'm just gonna kind of come
and phone it in yeah and that's that's
why those people were bombing and you
killed yeah so sometimes it's be more
likable sometimes it's at sprinkle in
take more beats sometimes it's you know
and it's always something in challenge
always challenge yourself to be better
so yeah it drives me nuts when people
get up on stage and just sort of like
the audience is coming to see the people
that are the best at this especially in
L.A yes these group shows so in common
someone just wants to do stand up
because they want to impress a girl or
they want to get laid or whatever like
that the audience is like I drove here I
got a sitter we watch Comedy we know
what good comedy is and it's and you're
being sloppy yep and you know comedy is
also like your outfits like you know
sometimes you get to a point you go I
have nothing new to wear I just don't
feel good yeah go to the Nordstroms
right go to Nordstrom's plural and get
your pillows and you you have to you
have to like there's two weeks ago I
thought I'm not looking forward to
getting up on stage I need to change
that I need to write to the point where
I'm excited to get up on these are great
men's t-shirts what is is this from the
last guy it's called true class oh am I
doing an ad now and uh promo code
Whitney yeah yeah thank you I'd like
them to sponsor what's wrong with trucks
so you get decision fatigue
yes absolutely I do not make game time
to say I basically on Sundays I know I
get made fun of for this fine I it
really works for me because my ADD is so
intense and I get really bad like
decision paralysis because perfectionism
leads to procrastination which leads to
paralysis right so I make as many
decisions as that t-shirt
on myspace.tv and uh uh I like to make
as many decisions as possible on Sundays
I pick out every outfit for the week on
Sunday remember you came to my closet
with me it was just like hanging out
yeah because if if you come over and I
need to make and I I just I just I clam
up and can I ask you something about the
closet
that's my closet though that's a that's
a different okay I understand you have
more clothes on that
what that's my like costume when you
took your shirt off in front of me was I
supposed to turn around or was I
supposed to like try and get a little
side you tell me I turned around because
I I thought this is so what happened
a white
floor I think that's a tampon your
tampon's out well I mean like orney this
is a sock do you think my pussy is this
large not that I thought maybe your flow
was that I'm not that super okay well so
Whitney takes her she was takes a bra
out and is now going to put the bra on
for the podcast in case you're wondering
how much I had to endure before we got
in front of the microphone I am the
female Luigi I just realized that I like
shove like the side of your and I go
this isn't right and I like turned
around like a like a nerd like I yeah I
should have you're a fucking dork I
should have taken that in that was my
moment right you were testing me you're
like let's see if he's a real man can
you strap the bra for me
what's up with men and still when they
try to take a woman's bra off they go
for the front clasp
okay I don't speak for all men but um I
think it depends on Oh no you're not
literal all of a sudden no I I think
that um it really depends what era you
came up in okay so I'm so old it was
still back bra so I still go for the
back but I I remember like 10 years out
of college it switched to the front
there was no notice there was no sort of
like hey everybody it's now in the front
and so you'd go for the back and she'd
go it's in the front and you're
humiliated okay at that point you're
like I don't know if I can keep it up
anymore because I've now been scolded
from my broad taking off technique as if
I haven't done this before so eventually
don't pretend that you weren't fucking
like fucking trying to be David
Copperfield with one hand like you guys
when they go with a one-handed I'm like
dude do you think that's a turn-on that
you could take a bra off with one hand
you think we're like oh that's so hot
he's taking off his so many these are
like the guys you don't know wow that's
cuter it's like how we pretend we
haven't done this before pretend you
haven't done it before I can do that I'm
very good at that yeah because you guys
keep switching the enclosure pretty soon
it's gonna be like it's on the side it's
on the side it's actually excuse me it's
actually bluetooth enabled so you're
gonna need to go on your phone download
an app and then you're gonna have to
sync up to myself and then you're gonna
have to un unhinge it yeah device
controlled by The Clapper yeah
so I like in the last like 10 years
hooking up with guys I feel like they
always like they'll be like here and I'm
like what are you doing and they're like
oh I'm looking for the class I'm like
what the fuck like you don't announce it
yeah I feel like these people have been
hooking up with a lot of like um
handicap people or something
somebody is going to invent the
Bluetooth enabled bra via app and I'm
going to be out of money this is Howie
Mandel would turn this into like half of
his Studio what's going on over there
Howie oh that's the Bluetooth enabled
bra so you never have to touch a woman's
breast yeah you know
there's the Yuki under boob sweat I mean
that's the thing no I was in I noticed I
was on his bike no I was on his podcast
and the lead singer from Kiss was there
yeah what is his name
it was a tie so
some person that will like go to dinner
with a friend and when you leave the
restaurant you'll like race to the car I
can't wait when I'm out with somebody I
just can't wait to get home do you still
race people in parking lots no I'm not
are you sure are you the guy that even
now you leave Applebee's and you're like
excuse me excuse me don't insult me and
then double insult me with Applebee's
don't top the insult with apples how
dare you come for Applebee's Applebee's
is amazing what's your restaurant okay
the last time I was in an hour vinegars
yeah what's your like chain
uh it used to be cheesecake and why did
it stop
I I just don't eat that anymore I don't
know why there's no cheesecakes around
me but if I'm on the road I'll go to
cheese because I know I'm not gonna get
food poisoning the amount of food they
give you makes it so you never have room
for the cheesecake
oh right okay cheesecake at the end but
my salad is like a it's this it's wild
the amount of food they give the last
time I was at Applebee's I go into the
bathroom the men's bathroom
and on the top of the trash is a
pregnancy test oh my God and it's
positive okay it's first of all it's in
the men's bathroom which means she must
have gone into they decided in the
middle I'll be pregnant now okay but
this was this is 10 years ago 15 years
ago she just they decided mid date at
Applebee's maybe we should check just to
make sure if I'm pregnant so she goes
into the woman's room takes a pregnancy
test must hand it off to him in the
men's room for verification and then
they don't even cover it up they don't
even like wrap it it's just sitting
there and I said you know what these are
not the people I want to be eating fried
food with I'll have my corn fritters
that uh I'll tell you what goes doesn't
go on a Cheesecake Factory there aren't
pregnancy tests no people are taking
covert tests there's no other everybody
goes there and they eat also I'm pretty
sure the name of the restaurant is
Applebee Applebee's
you know there's a Cheesecake Factories
like your Cheesecake Factories next to
Nordstroms at The Groves PF Changs but
that is that is correct
so uh I remember so
God when was this it was when eBay kind
of first started oh Craigslist sorry
when Craigslist first started there were
lots of women that would when they were
pregnant they would sell positive
pregnancy tests wow to other women so I
could go to you and go
I need a thousand bucks to take care of
this
wow
and I remember going fuck why when I was
21 I would
really yeah well I mean not 21. I just
mean would you've been the one selling
the pregnancy test or would you have
been the one buying the price when you
broke the kind of thing like this guy's
a fucking asshole anyway he cheated on
me whatever he's a shithead we're
breaking up anyway I can see myself
before I got into a program to re-parent
my brain and out of the scarcity complex
of like it's me versus the world and I'd
like have to do anything to survive I
can see myself being like Oh that's a
kind of good racket it's interesting I
haven't heard of that one yeah that's
that's pretty amazing wow yeah I think I
have uh the the tests when I was
positive for covet and I mean I saved
them you shave them that's a little
weird I might need them yeah really yeah
I can't make it I mean I've done it I'll
just send a picture of the positive
comatose I'm like I can't make it sorry
I would just take a pen and just fill it
in just two lines there you go I think
that would that it would be obvious I
like to call I'd like to turn calling in
sick into arts and crafts that's what I
like to do you're going you're at if I
get getting watercolors from fucking CPS
oh yeah no I would go to uh Jones
Fabrics the whole day Joanne Joanne's
Fabrics
say anything why do you hate men so much
you have to put us in a throat what if I
said why do women this why do women you
probably have the career you want yeah
okay I want to get back to what's your
career advice for onions I want to get
back to your story on the internet what
happened okay I want to get back to
right all this stuff down did certain
people pluralize things on purpose and I
or I never know I'm not trying to be
ironic sometimes I try to go like it's
like me going like you have food in your
tooth like it's Nordstrom like you're
you know what I mean like it's uh but if
you say I'm at Nordstrom
I like when people correct me like I was
saying things wrong well then you're
with the right guy I used to say it's
the best thing since life's Brad
and finally someone went what did you
just say and I went it's the best thing
since life spread and she was like it's
sliced Brad I was like what yeah I've
been saying this wrong my whole life and
no one's corrected me like I look like
such a fucking idiot and then I said you
were doing that on purpose no I mean not
on purpose I thought you were legit
stupid
you don't say any aphorisms or adages
wrong sure I do I say Nordstroms I get
stuff wrong all the time I thought it
was Chester drawers I gotta be honest
with you there's a misconception that
I'm intelligent and I'm not I get stuff
that's what intelligent people the time
all the time in fact people go what's
your IQ people say what's your IQ that
means nothing I don't even know what IQ
stands for I thought it stood for like
intelligence quiz that's right and then
I looked it up and it said intelligent
quotient I don't even know what quotient
means it's kind of the same thing I mean
what do you think uh do you know
what.com stands for
dot com yes the there's a website and
then there's a dot but what does com
stand for communication
communal uh why are you laughing because
it's so close to what Wendy thought it
was I thought it was dog computer okay
wait no uh dot uh what is it Compadre
oh really but here's the thing why do we
need that knowledge at all we don't that
is such nonsense it really is just you
know what uh this is your TV stand for
you're gonna be on a date with some girl
you're like and you're gonna saying
stands for DOT communication that you
won't fuck you be be that is what is hot
about men you know shit I don't know I
think that's hot when a guy's like oh
you know that this actually meant that
golf stands for gentleman only ladies
forbidden I it's not I love that but
then it becomes mansplaining and can't
be happening okay really I come from you
just got more attractive I come from
man's money because men know all the
stuff how else are we gonna learn it but
how do we know everything if we can't
get Nordstroms for pluralizing things
because I think you guys pretend to be
dumb on purpose sometimes and uh I
suspect a lot of the guys you're dating
are dumb they're actually dumb I haven't
met them but I'm I'm suspecting so
here's what here's what you guys do like
it's like when guys pretend they don't
know how to work the dishwasher so that
we're like I'll do it like I think a lot
of time I do it sometimes too I'll be
like I can't open this and so this is
what I'll do is that with the whole
coffee making thing was about because
the plug didn't work then you couldn't
get the cross then you couldn't turn the
coffee machine goes I can't turn the
coffee maker off I walk over I press the
button put a little Force into it a
little little you know testosterone is
that all your finger women I feel like
it is but right you just think about
that as much as you want and so
you know what I'm saying I'll go right
into the camera you can have that for
later you're trying to take the bra but
no I that's why I got so mad because I
do sometimes pretend I don't know how to
do something to set a precedent that
this is not something I'm gonna do
forever so you and then someone go I'll
just do it and I think guys I think we
are women right now are um
uh are think that receiving help means
you're weak or dumb and we're not men
like to need to have a purpose they need
to have something to do they need to fit
you know so you want to go back to more
traditional
role-playing of
CIS mail am I saying this correct no but
this thing where women are just like
I'll do it you're in I'll do it I'll do
it it's like just let someone else do
something for it's like when women are
like I can open my own door thank you
it's like okay well just let him do it
for him like what men need something to
do yeah like you're so independent that
you've what what do I you do you have a
dildo you have your own fucking car you
make your own money got it like why do
you need me you know so I think that for
me I have to go out of my way to go like
I am so independent I worked really hard
but if I want to be in a partnership I
can't be this independent right you know
because it's like we have different love
languages it's like me giving you a gift
and you not opening why is everybody
saying love language all of a sudden why
are we saying green flags red flags what
what I don't care love you know love
languages that I know how to turn on the
coffee maker this sounds real easy this
sounds like a a home run
remember David Letterman
used to throw I you don't remember David
Letterman I do yeah I do I love him I'll
tell you I did both shows in the same
year which was a huge accomplishment for
me yeah and when I did lighterman it
felt very cold it felt very short well
he does keep a studio at 58 degrees it
changed my opening joke this is going
back
25 years in New York City there used to
be you would take the bus you would do
shows and you'd go uptown on a on a
train or a Subway and then you go
Crosstown on a bus and I'm going cross
out on a bus and there's an ad on the
bus that says chances are somebody on
the bus says lupus
I look around I'm the only one on the
bus
I'm like I got a little
then it closes with right me going to
the doctors and then you know me calling
the doctor's office and then they're
saying is this the guy with lupus okay
so it calls back to the end the day I'm
doing Letterman I'm in the hotel and
George Shapiro my manager at the time
calls and says they don't they just ran
your stuff by Dave I've been running the
set for months I used to watch you every
night for months and give you notes well
I don't know what it was but I was on a
bus there were ads that said psoriasis
this is a real story I can always tell
like if you ask me where I was any time
I write a joke any any joke you can take
any drug and say where were you I can
tell you the etymology the or the
origination of the joke it's a real
story and when it's a real story comes
from your heart yes you know what I mean
yes and so so they said Dave
Dave is not comfortable with you saying
lupus and the writers we all got
together and we suggest you say
psoriasis now I've never told us on
stage before lupus is funny because
lupus is ambiguous about to say why is
lupus such a funny word it's a funny
word I think that that is fucking fishy
that's fishy and it's a word that you
that the disease that I think psoriasis
is totally it's it's comedy writers this
makes me think someone wanted to do a
little like you were stepping on
something someone wanted to do or they
wanted to own because you everybody
knows David Letterman's writers more
than anyone the lupus is so much funnier
than this lupus is a disease I think is
predominantly something that women get
okay which makes it even funnier it's
just so funny so Shapiro's now talking
me into he goes just do it this is why I
hate my career because I've been a softy
I've let this industry push me around
and instead of saying no you know
because we go okay we're Comics if we're
just compliant you'll let me do they if
I just kiss your and there's there's
been this thing of like if I get this
lawyer some of them went to law school
or some of them went to school for
advertising who now has a comedy agent
for no reason for no reason like
literally I don't even know why you do
do you hate comedy like why do you like
truly the only people that I will work
with in on the comedy side are people
that used to work in comedy clubs like
my manager Judy marmel was a waitress
yeah in comedy clubs yeah you know yeah
I know and I would rather work with
someone who actually like before they
were in comedy were in comedy in some
capacity now people like I'll just be a
comedy manager I mean it's just fucking
a bunch of just booking clowns and a
bunch of chuckle Huts like I don't know
so that to me is just it makes me so mad
it gets worse because then we go like if
I'm just nice if I just I'm nice to this
person and then it fucks you right and
the people that are assholes fucking win
and you're like I don't get it I should
have pulled my yourself from the show
nowadays you pull yourself on the show
and you'd blast it on the internet okay
but we didn't have that then so George
is like I suggest you do it otherwise
you'll never get on the show again so
they said hey just so you don't forget
we'll have a guy holding a cue card that
says psoriasis
so I'm about to do the show
I as I'm sitting backstage for the
curtains to open a guy this is going to
blow your mind comes up to me this is in
the dark so I don't know who it is and
he said hey Arnie he said you're a
really you know big comic
remember this is Dave's show
and then you hear Paul Shaffer play and
then and then you see three people bring
out uh carbonated drinks no they don't
put aspirin in they go ladies please
welcome
Ernie Adams right I walk out
and I'm gonna say I was on a bus and I
look around I see somebody wearing
there's there's a sign that somebody on
the bus has psoriasis I look up there's
a guy holding a sign that says psoriasis
and I hadn't thought about it that it
begins with with a p and goes to an S so
I'm like I have perserasis I have Cyrus
in my head I'm getting it wrong I mean
because you've done lupus so many times
so many I should have gone out and done
lupus and just said you because what
happens is like once you you get such
the muscle memory of it and then once
you go to the Super unfamiliar
environment and you're in fight or
flight and the adrenaline floods your
brain and you're like hippocampus just
shuts down yeah and you're you're in
front of all these cameras and back then
Letterman was the biggest the biggest
show that is the most high pressure high
stakes situation you could have been in
in that time yeah and when you do
Letterman like you're in New York they
clear the road but you can go on any
club you can walk in like he's doing
vitamin tomorrow night like it was a big
deal and so to have them mess with and
by the way lupus didn't get big laugh at
all Super Bowl for Comics at that time
yeah and then the next day I'm flying
home coach probably middle seat
and as I'm walking down the aisle a lady
comes up to me and she said hey I saw
you last night on Letterman and I just
want you to know I have psoriasis and
it's not funny and I said I know it's
not funny lupus is funny
and nobody ever the lupus Society I
think had me perform for them one year
they never objected to me being on a bus
I'm not making fun of people with lupus
I'm making fun of the stupid sign and
mathematically I'm the only one on the
bus do I have to explain this to the
Letterman writers
I'd like the documentary about that what
happened to orney's lupus joke on
Letterman
if anybody you want to come on to my
podcast what's wrong with trucks
with only Adams
Comedians and trailers podcast yeah
Comedians and trailers not being offered
drinks Comedians and uh Shasta
they can't make coffee yeah
I could never do a comedians in houses
getting coffee I wonder just comedians
trying to make coffee why is this you
know this is what happens with every
drink yeah the condensation they gotta
fix this I don't know how anyone
can date either of us who doesn't think
like us
like how does a girl respond to how mad
you are at that dream they're confused
yeah because they've been dating you
have boring Financial people people you
are the same level of angry when it
comes to like a horrible uh unfair thing
to happen to you in your career and like
a mug well I mean no but think about it
like why is this accepted why why so I
go I just want to have a drink I figure
we're gonna edit this so we'll cut away
what I'm gonna do this as if we're not
now it drips off I'm not editing out you
no I get no I figure this is if it's
like my podcast when if I'm taking a
dramatic condensation yes I'm furious
you can't it's dripping onto my pants it
looks like I pee peed myself and I'm
looking is that on camera I'm looking
how do you say if you're gonna go to the
bathroom what do you say uh urinates
you're saying I pluralize it I was with
someone the other day a guy who's like
I'm gonna go potty real quick well he
needs to grow up
he needs to grow up it was like I just
got to go potty like you're like 50. oh
you know what I say I say I'm gonna go
use the WC I go hang on WC I'm gonna go
use the WC that's what I do
um what tell me about a date with Ernie
Adams How does it go I want to talk
about that towards the end I want to
hear you it's my podcast you talk about
it when I want to talk why can't I hear
what happened to you online it's it is
the end
it's okay getting it in like 20 minutes
ago okay wait a minute don't look at my
license right here no but just okay well
I wanted to tell the one rose joke that
proves that you know doing these events
getting roasted these super powerful
billionaires if they can't be roasted
that's a problem well what happened to
you online I'm gonna tell you that in a
second so I was with all these like
super famous Tech billionaires Tech the
most powerful people in the world yeah
and they're signing up to be made fun of
you know I think there's a level of the
malignant narcissism of like I don't as
long as someone's talking about me no
give a shit I'm so rich look at this
little waitress making fun of me look at
her flirting with me but I did say um uh
I looked at the list of people attending
this event tonight and I thought it was
uh Lauren Sanchez's vision board you
know what I mean it was great yeah but
it's like you can do stuff like that you
know yeah
um uh the story okay so I
I get a lot of shit it's fine I don't
need to talk about it I don't even get
oxygen if people don't like me that's
totally fair I probably agree with you I
probably you know
it's matter it's like it does matter
when you're a comedian I think that if
you hate me hap like
maybe like maybe like 20 is actually
about why because I think that a woman
talking that you have no chance of
fucking who has opinions and it's it's
it's I get it you know what I mean I get
it like I don't know you're just trying
to make people laugh do you think maybe
they can attack you a lot I think that
people forgot if they don't like someone
they can just unfollow them or change
the channel they now or how about this
not say anything yeah but they're go I'm
gonna hate fuck this just don't watch it
you know you can turn the chat there's
literally more channels than ever
there's more content than ever just mute
me on follow me like if I if I'm people
think that they hate fuck you or they
kind of forgot that they have a choice
to not consume what you do at all yeah
but I think that we have a very rampant
self-righteous indignation addiction and
I think in 50 years we're going to look
back the way that we look back at like
smoking cigarettes while pregnant and
drinking during that we'll go remember
when like
people used to just follow people they
hated and just fucking trash them it was
it was an addiction it's an addiction I
think trolling is out because it just is
not as powerful as it used to be but
also trolling like it doesn't exist
because you can only troll if you're a
functioning adult who's making the
choice to troll I think we look at
people that shit on Us online and we
assume that they're all like men in
suits who are like at their law firm and
like give me a second I gotta say
Whitney's a piece of shit it's kids it's
like kids it could be Bots too it could
be Bots or kids so it's like we're
assuming everyone is like some brilliant
uh high functioning emotionally stable
person who's going you're a piece of
shit it's literally like if you walk by
a homeless person a meth zombie on
Melrose who's like you suck it's like us
going I do yeah don't say well you're
trolling me like that we that's what
these people are doing
um and you know when I was a kid we
would toilet paper people's houses we
would knock over their mailboxes we
would egg people's homes like we used to
do physical damage waste of toilet paper
and eggs but we used to do physical
damage to people's houses for no reason
so these are just kids being like fuck
you it's like Bill Burr when he was on
he said something that was like really
made me see it differently he was like
dude if when I was 16 I had a direct
line to my hero I would totally I would
be like hey motherfucker he's like
really he's like oh it would be funny
you know he was like I you're a kid like
you just want to get the attention of
someone that you like or don't like you
know and so um so I think we're like a
little ageist in that area uh both ways
because we're like you know a lot of
older people that are like you suck like
they just don't know how the internet
works I'm like you know this everyone
can see this right right you know what I
mean like I don't know what you're you
look crazy you know whereas um like
Roseanne you know I think that tweet was
totally not okay but there was you know
some ageism and like she's like well
what's it's I'm like Journal Twitter is
for journalists to find stories now
she's like oh it is I thought I was just
making a joke it's like that's not what
it is anymore but it's ages to assume
that you know the ecosystem of Twitter
you have to really keep up with what
it's about you know and so she learned
the hard way
um and uh so I'm used to getting shit on
I don't care it's fine please use me as
your punching bag my thing is like I
didn't sign up for how I made someone's
day so I would love to make you laugh if
you need to go she's a piece of shit and
you're like yeah fucking God if that's
how I make your day great right like if
that's where you get your dopamine
whatever like you know and so people
like we're clowns and some people go oh
clowns are fucking wild like fine we you
know and I know what I know what this is
so
this is what got me uh I get there's a
lot of like internet comedians that
don't do stand up and they do reaction
videos and they make fun of the people
that are taking risks they make fun of
the people that are in the arena they
make fun of the people that are putting
their ass on the line you're the
Roosevelt in the arena
is that
yeah Brown I thought that was brene
brown who no no I'm a man and we know
things that you don't know am I right
Theodore Roosevelt absolutely thank you
thank you by the way thank you they know
that uh thank you for mansplaining me
now I know you're welcome
you're welcome I'd like to take a moment
to tell you that um if anyone doesn't
want to be mansplained to it like why do
you want to stay dumb who cares how they
say it
who cares anyway in the arena how are we
going to learn if they don't tell us
you're telling me you knew that don't
man explain me people literally college
students are like uh my professor's
mansplaining me it's called teaching
yeah if you don't know it it's not
mansplaining it's teaching yeah
yeah you fucking cunt well here's the
thing and maybe you're guilty of this
too it seems like there's a lot of
inserting gender into something that's
not gendered yeah it's not it's not yeah
like like you know I I'm Jewish if if
you said uh hey uh or any why are you so
upset about uh you know condensation I'm
like what because I'm Jewish I can't
make fun of like it has nothing to do
with it and there's a lot of that
there's a lot of like people taking
their own issues men or even more
patronizing to other men right yeah I
mean it's like it's like the Chappelle
thing like I'm doing this a bit I think
you've seen it of like I'm talking about
the trans things I have so many
transgender friends and like I kind of
it's like with the Chappelle thing it's
it's Chappelle being one of the I think
best comedians who's ever lived uh and
if not the greatest and I just want to
tell my trans girlfriends like wait till
you see what he said about women for the
past 30 years
wait wait till you fully identify as a
woman you're gonna be really pissed if
what he said about trans women like
waiting to see what he said about women
the other thing is you don't know if
Chappelle or other comedians are trying
to evoke a reaction in a conversation so
that's right I I really believe like I
remember when I was doing comedy in New
York in the in the 90s there was a lot
of like like you would call it
homophobic there was a lot of making fun
of homosexuality and it really it caused
a discussion and I know a lot of people
will disagree with me with this and
think that this is wrong of me to say
but I think comedians are great at
causing a discussion you guys know me by
now
and you know what annoys me the most
about men in general there is no excuse
for you to be wearing a deep V
where I can like see the like Ed Hardy
dog tag
that your ex-girlfriend gave you like
what are we doing why does your shirt
have holes in the armpits why does it
come why does it come down to mid thigh
yeah or it's a crop top whoo it's a
t-shirt just don't overthink it just
normal shirts remember do you remember
when I want to start a business it was a
store it was just called normal shirts
and that's why our friends at true
classic have literally done that they
are Reinventing the T-shirt by just
making it the perfect t-shirt it is the
perfect simple thing that will make your
man look spicy because he will look like
a normal person true classic has already
helped over 2 million men look great in
their tees and now you can save big
while you look great at the same time
get 25 off true classic with our
exclusive link trueclassic.com Whitney
and the discount doesn't stop there
you'll save even more during their
sitewide sale support our show and check
them out at trueclassic.com Whitney the
best gift that you can grab is through
this is a trick it's a trick this copy
is is doing it up this is
this copy is bullying to people with
speech impediments and I am for it true
classic is a also a great gift
to grab it's a great stocking stuffer or
white elephant gift
a dick
that's on the body of a guy wearing true
Classics so true the men in your life
need this do them a favor anything you
want as long as you're not wearing a
v-neck it's too classic the number one
gift on their wish list and men don't
wait you're already late okay get 25 off
at trueclassic.com Whitney free shipping
included on purchases over 100 that's 25
off at trueclassic.com Whitney Santa
won't be the only one slang thanks to
True classic
I want to talk to you guys about a
magical device that will change your
life no it's not that sex toy with the
sucker thing that's all over social
media that thing is very weird and it
will chip your teeth be careful I want
to talk to you about composting I've
never been able to compost before it was
always just like too complicated or like
too much work or you had to like go like
to a place and hang out with people that
are like lifting a euphemism well if you
interrupt me on again I will I be so
grateful because I was gonna say can I
tell you something that was that's why
interrupting is so great I had no idea
what was where I was going and she
rescued me do you know what I'm saying
yes and baby yeah and also talking to
the microphone more we're sharing I'm
sharing with our new dude this is
you don't share with other women you
compete with them okay this is not how
the Hollywood Works listen
you know I've never done that before in
my life so true so I want to talk about
loamy I've heard all about loamy alomi
allows you to turn your food scraps into
dirt with the push of a button this is a
magic like some witchcraft stuff okay
it's a countertop electric composter
that turns scraps into dirt in under
four hours we have a new member of the
team named Katie Katie used it yesterday
and I've never seen a happier she was
happier than Jennifer Lopez on that
Italian vacation yes
what you yeah so I had lunch I had lunch
I had some Greek food I had some coffee
in the morning coffee grounds were still
there you know usually you just throw
them away they get everywhere took that
had my loamy took that took my leftovers
that I was gonna throw away my Greeks
out I was gonna toss threw it all into
loamy pressed a button and then I walked
away did some email that came back and I
literally spread soil in your garden for
you wild it just turns into dirt
magically it's so simple you can use it
on like your third day at one of the
most overwhelming jobs known to man
she was trying to bury herself alive
like I could just put myself to rest in
the garden right now even more right now
it was actually also the crazier part
and I don't even know if this is like
really lomi's angle but I've had an amp
problem for like six months because like
there's there's Rhymes and there's like
just like food everywhere where it's
just like I feel like I can't throw it
away I don't want to waste it and then I
kind of like put it in the fridge and
then it never gets eaten and it's like
now you just put it in the loamy and it
turns into soil where you can bury your
enemies with your trash so we're
producing less methane here at the
homestead instead I will turn my waist
into nutrient Rich dirt that I can feed
to my plants I threw a dinner party and
the food cleanup was a total Breeze uh
all my friends think I'm an Eco goddess
now it's no big deal if you want to
start making a positive environmental
impact uh or just like clean up after
dinner and make it easier and not have a
bunch of like weird like drippy bags
like near your door loamy is perfect for
you head to Lomi l-o-mi com slash
Whitney and use the promo code Whitney
to get fifty dollars off your loamy
that's fifty dollars off when you head
to lomi.com Whitney and use promo code
Whitney at checkout food waste is what
is it gross loamy is your solution with
the holidays just around the corner get
your family the dirt they deserve joking
loamy will make the perfect gift for
someone on your shopping list I actually
think this is a like what we should be
giving everyone for Christmas I am
giving this to someone for Christmas
turn your food waste into dirt with the
Press of a button with loamy use the
code Whitney to save fifty dollars at
loamy.com Whitney
can I tell you something yeah I actually
think when we go that was a joke trigger
warning we're actually
uh bullying
dumb people
go out of their way to intentionally
misunderstand what we're doing in order
to justify being offended yeah yeah but
I was gonna don't Pander to them I was
gonna do a bit I don't know much about
podcasting but when I look straight into
the camera it means I have something to
say that's important let's see it no
it's over the moment's playing the
audience moment's gone moment's gone
it's also not just uh people I'm not
such a narcissist that I think someone's
gonna go to jail for me it's like some
people are really drunk after the
pandemic people psychologically I mean I
have at my Dallas show with the Majestic
there was a guy was out for 12 seconds
there was a fight that broke out that
was so bad this guy was out for 12
seconds I have a video of it it's like
people are just kind of feral right now
and comedians are like people are just
mad at us because you can talk to us you
can we'll listen whereas like
politicians they won't you know so it's
like we're good people to be mad at
because it's probably gratifying because
we'll listen of course we're not as
powerful yeah we'll internalize it you
know you can reach us you know you can't
reach fucking Biden or Kamala or
whatever you're fucking mad at you know
you can get to us and we'll talk about
you on a podcast for two hours you know
it's worth a worthwhile I like the Dalai
Lama um but so tell me about your dating
life
I find it I find it very difficult why
to connect what do we do we have
carbohydrates what are we oh I'm having
a lifesaver I I find it uh you know hard
to connect with people
I bet
I find it's hard to have an honest
conversation but I think that also
comedians we have a very hard time
biting our fucking tongues you know what
I mean and because we have such a deep
obsession with Justice we will die on
any fucking Hill and I have a really
hard time in relationships like I get
stuck sorry I get stuck you just
apologize to a microphone to myself
foreign
how much fun are we having
so I guess not that much A lot
um eight out of ten
um is that what you said you're an eight
on stage I'm an eight I'm a solid eight
let me tell you something when I'm on
stage but here's the thing everybody
wants to sleep with me I bet everybody
even people that didn't even know they
were attracted to a man become attracted
to you because you're very fucking Alpha
and it's hot yeah I like that on stage
off stage not so much right off stage so
I have to offer it up off State off
stage I'm like a six but because you
talk like this be the just don't you're
the shit yeah be delusionally confident
you project onto people what do you mean
I project you project do you know what
project means yes what does it mean you
tell me man explain me no you put you
make assumptions about what people are
thinking you have I'm a piece of shit in
the center of the universe syndrome
because I've been at restaurants
yes they are no offense yes they are why
people took videos they posted it look
at loser from Teen Wolf eating alone
yeah yeah I'd rather you be alone than
sitting there with like an 18 year old
fucking actress that's weird mm-hmm I
agree when a man is like I would rather
eat alone than be with someone that
makes me feel alone is hot you and I are
very similar and that we are like a dog
with a bone sometimes and just because
it's true doesn't mean it needs to be
said and I think that very few people
uh I think the reason comedians are so
like special and fun to watch is because
we
obsess over the things nobody really
notices until we say it do you know what
I mean of like I'm gonna fucking doilies
what the fucking point and then you know
and everything is funny he's like oh
I've never been mad about that but now
that you say it I understand that it's
ridiculous but we don't turn it off
right you know and so most people I
don't think want to go through their
life questioning all the little things
that actually kind of give them joy we
were we ruin things for people we're
like Party Poopers we're like this
fucking glass like I you know never
really have been mad about the
condensation on a Frappuccino and now I
can never you ruined them yeah I've
ruined it but usually that's what we do
but I also think in Los Angeles women
think because you're a comedian maybe
you're not that successful I think that
when you're in your 20s and you're a
comedian it's exotic it's sexy there's
the potential that you're gonna get your
own TV show you can have all these
specials it's gonna be huge so people
don't even know if I'm successful but
when I meet someone yeah I'm a comedian
I say with pride they're like oh okay
but why
weeding out starfuckers that's a good
thing no because women I I think you
want to be what's like I want to be with
a woman that's successful or whatever
she does okay I don't want somebody who
they think most Comedians and maybe are
living with roommates or whatever it is
you know yeah yeah yeah yeah right yeah
yeah they go okay you're a comedian but
you haven't how come I don't really know
you just say Google me like do I mean
it's two things number one I think a lot
of people pretend they don't know us
when they do and then you have to be in
this weird fucking improv scene that is
weird yeah where do I know you're from
yeah can you just Google me and if you
don't know me it's fine but don't make
me do this or you're on an elevator
you're talking to all 12 floors and they
get out and they go I think you're funny
or I love your comedy well why didn't
you bring it up before well you know
because they're nervous and a lot of
them are embarrassed because I think
they go like because actors are such
fucking dickheads they spend their whole
life trying to get famous and then they
walk through the world like none of
these people are allowed to talk to me
the very people that paid to see my
movie and got me famous so I think a lot
of people you know when someone's like I
really don't want to bother the internet
I'm like bother me please right I didn't
work this hard to get known no one to
say thank you I think you're funny
here's the other thing this is the only
thing keeping me going because if I
looked at Twitter I would quit these
people that come up to me in airports
and say I think you're funny is the only
reason I keep doing this here's the
other thing do it when I'm on a date do
it when I'm with people people come up
to me all the time when I'm alone well
yeah but they don't when I'm with
somebody they don't want to interrupt
interrupt here's what I want that person
to know yeah I want something to
interrupt but also I think that the one
thing I will say about that is there's a
a gal are you having like an Axis or
like a refund because that's yeah how
did you see that you've had it a few
times but that's that's a Jewish thing
it's a gag reflex that's a Jewish thing
that's your 409 that's only half you
yeah I don't like when they sneak
pictures
I like come up and ask to take a picture
well yeah just go hey sometimes I sneak
pictures yeah I don't like that
don't be scared you're intimidating I'm
very approachable no you're not what are
you talking about I love when people
come up to me I love it after shows I
love it we are we come off Brusque to
people
we are scary to people Brusque
white Brusque yeah I am learning this
just now like this the guy that was
rough on me on Twitter I'm like crying
in my bed
Marlo Stern is like it's you know you're
you come off so fucking tough that it
doesn't occur to anyone that they could
hurt you right I get that okay so people
say that to me they go oh here's the
other you date women oh I'm not gonna
pump your ego you're like no pump my ego
tell me it's like a card of people that
Comics are insecure so people are very
hypocritical when it comes to Comics
they go all comedians are mentally ill
right like all comedians are traumatized
right and then they're like fuck Comics
they're bullies it's like right you just
said you were meant that we were
mentally ill and sick and you know that
but now all of a sudden you think I'm
this egomaniac who is secure with myself
which is it guys I I just feel like as
far as dating I'm not going to settle I
would never settle and I think that it's
interesting that you get to a certain
age and people look down oh you ever
been married yeah you don't have any
kids dude
you're the one that has a problem with
marriage not me yeah yeah you know
Brandon has this really thing he's like
you would rather me have gotten married
I think it's like and my wife like fall
off a cliff then never have been married
you know what I mean like you would
rather me have been in a bad marriage
right than not be married at all the
other thing is if you're gonna succeed
in comedy it's full-time full Focus it's
tunnel vision for 20 years and then you
come out of it and maybe you meet
somebody yeah would you date somebody
that had been married and has kids of
course I am very I would I was thinking
about this the other day I uh uh would
love to date someone who's been married
because I think they know the deal like
they know that it takes work they know
it's hard you know there's no like
illusion and they don't want a big
wedding probably or whatever nonsense or
whatever yeah bachelor party but most
people don't get to do what we do yeah
you know I was like what if he had kids
I've dated guys with kids and I I'm very
Pro that really yeah very Pro I'd love
to date guys with kids okay yeah
um but uh uh you okay so here's the
thing we get in our own way in personal
relationships because we will die on any
fucking Hill so I'm the person who's
like all the person needs to hear is I'm
sorry their love language is verbal um
get used to it back to Loveland and it's
helpful it's really fucking helpful even
though it sounds fucking corny
um I thought it was corny first at two
but two but it's helpful because the way
that I give love is not often the way
people receive love and the way that
other people give love I don't really
value verbal I don't value at all like
when someone says I love you it like I'm
like what did you do hmm like why are
you saying that yeah what's happening
like what like you're trying to
manipulate me like if I if you love me
I'll know you don't need to tell me like
I'm like like the guy was dating it was
like
uh you know I was like don't say I love
you to me I'll I'll let you know when
you love me like I'll know well way to
shut it down well I don't want to hear
it too early because it's it can be why
not if he feels it let him say it don't
stop him don't stop the train but I it's
I don't know I just want to spend the
rest of your life with not being able to
make coffee but do not be able to grind
your own beans is this what you want
Whitney
don't shut down the I let him say it but
we what is your definition of love let's
agree on it because mine is different
than yours why do you why does your why
did why why do people have to Define
everything why do you need to fight with
a natural phenomenon called condensation
because it's gotta end they've got to be
able to make cups that it doesn't drip
all over me
here's the other problem I have with
dating and I think well I also do this
it's like when someone just needs to
hear I'm sorry I'm like but I'm not
sorry give it okay good you know what I
mean i i i i s what I did the impact
might have been different than my
intention I am sorry about that but if I
apologize to you right now and I don't
mean it well both I'll lose respect for
you if you buy it and we'll both always
know that this is so is there anything
more condescending than the fake apology
I'm like I'm sorry I'm sorry I feel that
way sorry I made you feel that way I am
sorry that I I I got it wrong like I'm
sorry like I thought I was being helpful
to you and I did the best I could and I
I missed yeah I'm sorry about that but
I'm not sorry because I really did try
but people say I'm sorry this is so
constant I'm sorry I made you feel that
way like they're empowering them I'm
sorry you took it that way yeah I'm
sorry that I have the shower over you
that's shitty I mean I am a obsessed
with apologizing I do a 10 step every
night oh my part I'm so sorry I said
that I should like I'm gonna what yeah
if I if to keep my side of the street
clean if I did something that was
manipulative something that was uh you
know uh superiority complex or
self-righteous indignation or you know I
I'm in a 12-step program Al-Anon and ACA
where you do that you take
responsibility for that so I will which
is ACA adult child of alcoholic okay so
I will apologize for things where people
that was I'm not what do you mean I
didn't even notice that I'm like I I you
probably never noticed but I would like
to apologize because I know what I was
doing and you might not even notice it
but if I did something or my intention
was pure and then it misfired because
I'm fucking off you know and I'm bad at
this or I don't understand how you
receive love
I'm sorry about the impact but that
wasn't my intention right so that's I
think what fucking comedians can't just
take a fucking dick in the mouth
sometimes and bite our tongs and just go
I'm sorry
there's that perhaps and where my mind
went when you were talking was I think
one thing we're all really good at
but that's going to screw up the
continuity
Girl Scout cookie no yeah kind of the
one thing that it's closer to me don't
but I'm the man and the man always gets
the girls have you ever come close to
proposing to someone yeah absolutely
what happened don't make the noises
don't make the noise don't make the
noise no no don't make the noise they'll
freak out yeah put it under here
okay yes but don't eat on the don't eat
on the mic okay sorry oh dude you made
the noise I know here's what um
Grace came on here and ate a chicken
sandwich and we lost like 10 000
subscribers
we can't eat on podcasts
yeah I know just finish what you're
saying well let me finish this and um oh
my God then mints are so fucking good
which is a sponsor I can get behind this
girl scouts
um what's your favorite Girl Scout
cookie this really wow red flags
not even a close second the dogs now
eating the girls got cookies okay
I think comedians have trouble because
we're really good at communicating
really good at communicating and a lot
of people hey buddy nobody I have to
we're really good at winning an argument
look how much this dog loves me
he's the best buddy good boy do you want
to smell my Girl Scout cookie do you
have a dog no that is wild that is that
is sick
thank you why don't you have a dog
because I can barely take care of myself
I've got a dog you'd be better at it I'm
sure I'd be I'm not I'm not doing a good
job right now
whoa and he got spit all over his face
doing that this yeah it's Christine
that's your loogie okay finish it
I think I think that comedians
Frank come here bud Frank come here I
think comedian I can't accept
unconditional love I just saw it happen
okay so there we have it on camera yeah
come on I think that um
I think that um
yeah don't you think that we're really
good at communicating and other people
are more close we'll say over
communicate for no reason I think
comedians we overthink and we over talk
and most people don't have the bandwidth
for it and we we we think we're good
communicators but we are Superfluous
communicators okay you know and most
people don't want the 20-minute
breakdown of how my childhood made it so
that this is like we over analyze and
most people it just I think comes off
guilty to people it comes off like we're
trying to not be accountable for our
Behavior because we go like oh I texted
my ex whatever and didn't tell you well
okay so I'm in this program and like you
know like we have to because that's what
we do is Comics is we break things down
from every angle and we have to like we
have to we're lawyers you know I say
like we comedians are basically lawyers
that we say something that's not true
and then we prove it with jokes you know
it's kind of what we do and and any time
we see everything as a debate that needs
to be won and we will not settle if
something's either unfair or we don't
feel understood so when someone's like
you're texting you're actually okay but
this is about in my inner child and this
and then I just want to really make I
just want to make amends we can't just
go like I'm sorry
if I was in your shoes I'd be spooked
too it doesn't matter why I did it
really I can I can give you a two
sentence synopsis
um and I'm sorry yeah that sucks do you
think it's possible we're not as
interesting as we think we are
foreign
I mean numbers don't lie podcast numbers
don't lie I mean no I'm talking about on
dates oh yeah I think comedians talking
on podcasts is interesting to people
even when we're fucking boring people
seem to like it you know maybe not me
but like you know uh on dates no I think
we're snobs hmm I think we're snobs hmm
I think comedians are fucking snobs
every female comedian I know is like I
want to date with this guy is not that
funny I'm like
you're a fucking snob you you own why
what imagine being on a date with a
female comedian and being like huh are
you the only thing that has kept us from
getting murdered for thousands of years
is laughing at Men's jokes that aren't
funny you don't get to fucking now be
like like you know so I think that
comedians we have this deep allergy to
pretending and the first couple dates
for everyone is a little bit of
pretending and we want to fucking share
our trauma the first 10 minutes no one
needs to be talking about their fucking
trauma on their first second third or
X's or X's what are you doing why do
people do that it's just a it I think
people there's people conflate being
interesting with over sharing we are in
an epidemic of over sharing but is it
possible these women that I go out on
dates with who are interested in me this
isn't I'm trying to push me away they
talk about their exes are they trying to
show me that they're wanted or have been
wanted in the past what what's the
psychology there
I have never understood that I believe
that anyone that talks negatively about
their ex is a red flag or just talks
about their past we don't need to hear
that or that's something for six months
eight months okay here's the deal here's
what happened like and here's my part in
it this whole man do it too guys do it
too they'll be like oh my last sex is
crazy it's like then why'd you date her
for four years the X before that fucking
stalker the common denominator it seems
to be you right so what's up if you like
crazy women I'm not the one if you want
a woman fucking call you a million times
if you're just stalking me like I'm not
your guy yeah you know so I think that
for me it I just ask as many questions
as possible
um because I'll be bored by someone else
if I don't ask them the right questions
right you know I feel that way too and I
find a lot of people don't ask me
interesting questions I think if
someone's boring it's your fault
you know some people are just boring
that's true but they're apparently
boring I'm so interested in people and
curious about people if someone's
inherently boring I'm still sort of like
how does this person get so fucking
boring I gotta know like there's nothing
more interesting than someone who's just
bought thinks they're interest so I'm
like okay do your parents read to you
like I need to know but I'll go out and
this happens I'll go out on a date and
I'll leave knowing everything about her
and she has no idea fine if my parents
are still married
I don't yeah I don't are you mostly
dating like actresses I try not to
influencers no
I like professionals doctors lawyers and
real people and they don't ask you about
yourself some do some don't there's a
lot of guarded you know you get to a
certain age people tend to be guarded
they tend to know a lot of people talk
about on dates I can't even imagine are
you afraid you'll never find love
uh no oh good no good but I also don't
need love to come only from a man I
think that it's uh really toxic and
unhealthy this whole thing of like I
just want to marry my best friend what
no marry a man and have a best friend
you can't get all your emotional needs
met from your partner it's psychotic you
know and I think we put way too much
pressure on I need to get all you need
to be my best friend you need my
girlfriend you need to be my boyfriend
you need to be my mom you need my dad
you need to be a handyman you need to be
all these things everybody's saying the
same thing
who understands you know I want to lose
who's in touch or whatever what are you
saying I don't know they're just be
specific people just uh I don't know
what the word this is like uh they
blather they ramble they they read one
self-help book on dating and they're
regurgitating catchphrases which is
gaslighting which is uh red flag green
flag yellow flag blue flag which is love
language which is you know I want
somebody who's their authentic self
what does that mean I don't I want
someone's best self that I I want the
person who can fake it yeah 30 years
that's right and get in my will that's
right get the hell out of my life if
you're gonna fall apart go do it with
your girlfriends yeah yeah not on my
walk that's the oh I mean and you're uh
taking my other major uh Insight on all
this is do not take relationship advice
from single people
hmm really
I give great marriage advice really yeah
get out
it doesn't work but wait I feel I just
50 of marriages end in divorce 50
because I think people get married it
takes two years to even know someone's
character 40 murder
[Applause]
yes married people die every day from
very suspicious things very like what
Bob walking backwards off a cliff having
their picture taken
married people drown in three inches of
water in their bathtubs
good news for you I fill my bathtub all
the way up and I live
Gatorade mixed with engine coolant
I am Gatorade at home when I get home
still going to be Gatorade still gonna
be Gator I'll sickle you ever heard of a
single person you ever seen the Dateline
where the single person falls down a
flight of stairs and dies no single
people that have walked down a flight of
stairs
oh my God it's just too real it is like
I know a lot of men and women in like
their 40s that are married just like
having like aneurysms and blood clots
and it is a little bit fishy yeah and
like his her husband perfectly healthy
died on a treadmill it's like yeah
not at all stupid like who's healthy as
a horse like it's always like that a lot
of choking a lot of dying scuba diving
yeah
when they come up the gears missing and
stuff I would never have I lost sight I
turned around I would never a lot of jet
ski accidents yeah I would never go on a
boat with a Man Who Loved Me I agree I
would never do it yeah this is scuba
diving is not a couple's uh no outing no
no you do it alone you do it with the
guy and you survive yeah you do it with
a couple of guys that know how to do it
you know you don't just go there and
yeah it is true when you die in fires
because you go back in to get your wife
yeah you know what I mean that is so
true they choke aren't most of your
friends uh getting divorced or no yeah I
have friends that are miserably married
some in open relationships
they hate their kids I'm not I'm against
it doesn't work you're either in it
you're either in it or you're not in it
that's why I'm not like a cheater I'm
just you're I'm all in you never change
did I probably did when I was younger
like college but no I I don't uh I love
monogamy I love having one per I know
this makes me sound like a wuss no it
doesn't it makes you sound like you a
murderer yeah I just exactly same when a
man wants to be monogamous it's so funny
because when a man is like I'm in a
monogamy I'm like why like that's
suspicious you don't have to yeah like
look I I'm like like when I see a woman
and I think she's gorgeous and then I
see who's the most beautiful actress too
I see a most beautiful famous person I
see a wedding ring I think thank God I
don't have to hit on her thank God she's
off the books that's so weird because I
feel like when I was engaged and had a
ring on I was flirted with more than I'd
ever been flirted with yeah those guys
are pigs that's not me because they knew
they didn't have to commit to me yeah I
don't know yeah yeah she's married
perfect person if you reject if you
reject them well you reject them because
you're married I know some guys that are
into married women and it's I really
it's kind of that reason I think this is
like there's no pressure I have a lot of
friends that hate their kids hate their
kids because they're doing too much
parenting kids aren't meant to be hung
out with this much it's just too much
meant to be in factories making toys
toys in China yes so so so okay last
thing and I know we have to go and we'll
do this again we'll do round two I just
don't want to be so long and you know
um uh dating what are red flags for you
in a person because I feel like you're
missing some red flags and this is why
people this is why people talk about red
flags yeah because people miss them but
you didn't get to me you missed if you
went on a date with something that
didn't ask you any questions about
yourself you missed a bunch of red flags
well I mean I like to hop into the date
right away I like to you know get right
here a lot of guys like to text for four
months before you actually even meet
you're these are the wrong guys you need
a guy like me knows how to make coffee
knows when an outlet isn't working sits
through the stupid tour says a few
things about well we just lost the view
you know whatever yeah but fun have you
dated a comic one time here's what I'll
say by the way things that comic stated
Comics that we make each other laugh
sometimes the non-comics is mean they
think it's mean yes and complaining yes
so we're bombing because we're doing
jokes out of content I had a woman say
to me uh the other day she goes you're
judging me I said yeah I am
I am that's what dating is I go yeah I'm
judging you you're judging me too yeah
that's what we do here that's all we do
we look around we're judging people that
guy's he's wearing the wrong shoes
they're all judging people comedians are
just better at it crazy and crazy enough
to say it out loud yeah that's what we
do yeah
um but wait I like being alone too much
maybe it's I like being here yeah I need
a lot of we're very good at being alone
yeah but and a lot of people interpret
that as a rejection you need someone
there can't be it can't be in Congress
how much someone can give and how much
someone needs also they get upset if I
work too much I love to work like even
being at the computer writing I'm
getting interrupted like I feel like
there's you know you need to date
someone with a job yeah I agree it's
gone yeah that respects what you do
mm-hmm
yeah why where are you I I just this is
not in L.A that's not true okay Dallas
is La now Austin is more La than La L
this whole thing that La is fucking
blondes with big tits and they're
shallow those people are everywhere now
La is like I feel like most people I
know in LA are they're like I don't know
you mean they're like I'm not on
Instagram anymore I just don't I don't I
don't
like I think every city is what you make
of it and you can build a case to say
the city socks and it's shallow but it's
just like the people that we want to
hang out with they're just not out at
bars they're probably at home you know
like it's just they're they're to me by
the way there's enough for them to be in
LA and in Austin and Boston in New York
they're everywhere but everybody is just
talking about themselves nobody is
curious and asking questions okay that's
the problem yeah but I feel like like I
was at this uh the Bros Premiere and um
that movie is it's very it's fucking
hilarious oh people are like make it
going after it on Twitter and stuff
aren't they well because I think it was
like marketed as you have to come watch
this it's a historical event and I don't
think people like to be
forced into doing something it was it
was marketed as if it wasn't a fucking
hilarious movie like why are you like I
think the best way to Market a movie now
is just let it come out and let Twitter
do the work it's like that's what
happened with Borat Borah it was like
this is the funniest like let P like I
think we're back to Word of Mouth I
think people are billboard Billboards
and ads we're kind of like why are you
pushing this so hard this can't is this
movie can't be good you know we're back
to like your funniest friend going dude
I just saw that movie it's fucking
hilarious and then you'll go see it you
know we don't trust
um ads anymore I think
um and uh yeah the movie's hilarious
what am I saying oh and then there was
this like cute guy there uh that we kind
of like both got lost to find parking
and we're kind of walking to parking and
it was kind of like cute and we had this
like little like kind of thing and then
I was like that was weird and I was like
oh no I can't date this person because
he goes to movie premieres right you
know what I mean the place I met him is
the red flag
yeah but not necessarily
disagree did you why because I just if
someone maybe of commonalities
did you get his number I don't want to
date anyone that has anything common
with me
did you guys no no he was like and then
he was of course he was like an agent or
something I was like if I meet someone
at a bar two in the morning you're
dating this trouble too you're dating
the guy that stays at the bar till two
in the morning you're not gonna change
that guy do you have this problem too I
can't tell if women are flirting with me
because they know me from something or
they're really interesting so a lot of
times like I used to be the shyest guy
like I would never asked you shouldn't
care people guys don't flirt with me
they come up to me and they're mean to
me they're like hey comedian hot like
that I just attract like people just
like put me in my place and it just ends
up getting mean yeah
I'm sorry you're going through no it's
okay it's fine but but I don't think you
need to worry about why someone likes
you no because then I put the mental
effort like they'll contact me on
Instagram after a show I'll put it out
everyone has that problem they're seeing
somebody already it's not even famous
people it's like doctors lawyers like I
don't know really yeah because doctors
well I'm saying now you can reach out to
someone and you know their job before
you meet they're very flirty why are
they flirty if they're in a relationship
I want to contact the other person and
go hey this is what's going on behind
your back yeah because they might be
getting flirting used to have integrity
no it didn't yes it did no it didn't
flirted if you were available you liked
the person where was this this was in
the 20s in the Massachusetts
1920s Salem up in Salem where you went
to school yeah where you went to the
school house I went to the Louisa May
all caught the loogie mail yeah okay
yeah I I just think some people are
crazy and some people aren't and it's
always a needle in a needle sack that's
most people are done if you wanted a
needle in the needle stack is a needle
in a needle stack no no
please tell me you're being funny try to
find a needle and a needle no
I know but it'd be even harder to find a
specific needle in a needle no it
wouldn't because you just go oh look at
all these needles I've just grabbed this
one no you're looking for a specific one
why are you so obsessed with that one
needle you have all these other needles
this is what's wrong this is why you're
single Whitney you've got all these
needles and you're going through the
prickly needle stack trying to find the
right needle just take any needle take
any needle because all the needles are
gonna hurt you just as much they're just
as pointy and not mine is details are
full of vitamin IVs and peptides yeah
needles every needle I use fucking
benefits me
um I uh that's really interesting I'm
fascinated by this I think we have a
similar thing but I think imagine the
opposite what if everyone was cool
be great exhausting you're like I'm
gonna date everyone it's not people have
to we need contrast and you're not going
to appreciate what you have if if most
people aren't most people aren't a match
you know if you went to a bar and
everyone was awesome you'd be like this
is I'm gonna cheat on all of you with
all of you yeah it would just be
exhausting you know so I think it's good
that most people uh don't Vibe with us
because then all you would do is fall in
love with everyone you met exhausting
yeah
oh when I'm right I'm right you're
always right yeah you are I'm my thing
is I'm always eventually right
event just let me fit just let let me
get there in six months you're gonna go
that was a good point um
where are you touring soon no
are you what are we promoting nothing
just your podcast my podcast yeah just
at least call it like trailer trash or
something no it's called what's wrong
with the one of the atoms that's what
the graphic says okay and uh today we
learn what is yeah in my uh my special
more than loud on YouTube awesome I
encourage because you know morning is
truly when I say I mean one of the best
comedians performing today I feel like
people are talking about you now the way
they talked about Burr uh 12 years ago
so I have 12 more years of this
well now they have the internet it will
speed it up
that's I just and that's a huge
compliment I just gave you the biggest
compliment I think I've ever given a
comedian and you had you did that well
let's do it again
do it again no because my my head got
caught up that I did do this for 12 more
years but do it again take two I'm done
complimenting you no but please well you
called me hot no I have to go it's 2 45
I have to film some other stuff and then
I have to go down to a doctor who's
going to break up the scar tissue in my
chest is this how your podcast ends you
yell at the cast first
I've been yelling at you this whole time
uh I and these very awkwardly I thank
you for that compliment I thank you no I
really do I appreciate it I know and
it's hard for me to listen I know I know
I've been I wouldn't be able to receive
that compliment yeah and and uh I'm just
telling the fans like so they go see
more than loud on YouTube
thank you people want to find good
comedians they want to see you they just
need to know about you and just live
it's so different it's such a different
vibe it's so cool going to a live seeing
it live what we do versus YouTube Yeah
but better people can't either can't
afford it or don't know about it you
know because I'll go with my I mean I
Grace Jones
Hollywood Bowl did you know that
recently yes I didn't know a week ago
Grace fucking Jones was at the Hollywood
Bowl I had no idea
how did that get to me you can you have
to literally to watch someone's Netflix
special you have to type in their entire
name like you cannot accidentally hear
that someone's in town that you like
when I go to fucking do shows I do five
shows in Houston 8 000 seats I go to the
airport to leave and so I was like when
you got me what are you doing here and
I'm like how unbelievable did you not
hear you recognize me with no makeup in
an airport you know me that well and
didn't know I was performing a mile from
your house and you follow me on like I
don't know it's a fucking Easter egg
hunt I don't know what to tell you yeah
there's too much going on like I want to
go see my heroes and I don't know I have
to follow the venue I guess I have to
follow the Hollywood Bowl and get their
newsletter right or you'll promote it
we'll take Twitter right you go I'm in
Houston next week I mean you and then
the week after you leave Houston people
post when are you gonna be in Houston
always but you follow me on Twitter how
did you miss the five required posts
that the venue made me do and that's
what you get for being fans of ours you
will pay
at least you know and I'm being serious
when you go back to Houston you've got
at least one ticket sold already
I love you guys or Ney Adams all right
elephants goodbye
[Music]
[Applause]